at the End of
Time 13
oock hey everybody what's going on it's
Wednesday night Tom has his aggressive
shirt on yeah yeah that's that's what he
called it when he first came and sat
down I'm like are you going to be back
there like rubbing your nipples and
stuff and distracting everyone from the
show you know how you do this shit's
[__] kind of low you
know yeah he's trying to like he's
trying to draw them all in yeah sure I
know I mean that's how he's going to be
doing that behind me the whole show it's
and I'm G to be like losing my place in
the notes and be like what would you
stop
it but you know so hey everybody it's
Wednesday night you guys know what that
means that means it's our main show uh
this topic won handily in the poll as I
suspected that it would I thought that a
long time ago I had had um the mam moros
cult in the running for you know topics
and stuff but I don't know if we ever
talked about it or you know it just got
deleted from the list somehow but it's
like I find but somebody recommended um
you know a couple weeks back or
something it's like you should do a show
about um adalo constanzo and the mamor
cult or the Narco satanists as they're
sometimes called even though technically
they're not satanists but we'll get into
that there was this was happened during
the late 80s it was Prime satanic Panic
time but uh this is some um messed up
[__] gonna be some sick [__] this some
messed up [__] um I'm just telling you
right now as you know I'm sure people
that are regulars of this show uh are
probably familiar with this and are
probably familiar with it I mean this is
one of the most messed up this is one of
the things and I don't know if this was
really the thing that made the satanic
Panic go crazy because I think it had
kind of been going on prior to this but
this case was kind of like the exception
that proved the rule because you know
how there was during the satanic Panic
there was all this thing about oh my God
people are like sacrificing people to
Satan and you know for power for black
magic and all this other kind of [__]
and largely that was not happening but
in this case it did happen yeah in
Mexico the [__] was happening that's
absolutely what was happening uh in in
this particular case like I said um all
of the victims and they don't know how
many there
were um were Mexican except for one very
famous American case whose name was Mark
Kilroy he was on America's Most Wanted
and stuff like that so we'll be talking
about that also and honestly like him
getting uh kidnapped and horribly
murdered um was kind of the thing that
brought the whole cult down as far as we
know that they're not still out there
because most of them are in prison or
dead but yeah um this is uh like I said
it's pretty messed up and I watched like
a whole bunch of different documentaries
about this zanada sent me uh like a half
hour long like interview with one of the
cops who was actually I think he was
from Brownsville Texas because they kind
of worked together because Brownsville
right is right on the border and um and
he was like they interviewed him and it
was like a really good interview like
where he talked about all kind of stuff
cuz he was there like when all a lot of
stuff was happened like investigated and
everything and they had um like police
footage of the guy that went there when
they found the bodies and all this other
kind of [__] so yeah Zander said I know
a lot about this case yeah so um so if I
mess up any pronunciations or any facts
or something like that cuz I kind of
went it's it's a very involved case um
so I kind of tried to keep
it but there's like a lot of other stuff
like going on around you know and
particularly with um the way that the
cult might have had connections to like
kind of hire up government officials
like a dude that was like uh you know in
interpole and stuff like that um which
maybe helped them get away with [__]
well they know for sure that they had
cop connections because there were a lot
of corrupt cops going on and so it kind
of made them seem like they were
actually magical because they were
working for the drug cartels and they
were saying it's like hey um you know
you better not do this on this
particular day that's what the magic
says but really they had like
Connections in the cops so they knew
what was going on but it made them seem
like a lot more powerful you know what I
mean so there was a lot of that going on
too illusion of power right uh yeah Zan
said Mexicans take witchcraft seriously
they yeah and you can that will be very
apparent as we talk about this case very
apparent Central and South America are
just are very different from North
America mostly because of religious
Traditions um I partially grew up in s
Pao Brazil my family was there for 12
years I was there probably a total of
maybe like four and broken up in a
couple things because I I went off and
join came back to the United States and
joined the army and stuff
um Central and South America are of
course are more Catholic and the
Catholic system has kind of an extended
uner expanded universe that's a good way
of putting it yeah and uh
and in that expanded universe are like
people's Saints you know it' be a good
way like a system of saints and Angels
and Demons all
right well they're mostly kind of
innocuous it's kind of like poor people
Saints and
stuff uh other ones are like saints that
criminals uh [__] will have offerings
too and these tend to be kind of like
satanic type stuff what we would
consider demonic or satanic sh when I
was in Brazil uh you know a lot of my
working class friends you know who were
like taxi cab drivers and just people
that I knew they were catholic but they
would regularly go to [__] makumba uh
rituals you know I would go with them
and they weren't satanic it was no like
an alternate Church an
alternate church where you could go and
kind of like pay
for help that the the official Church
wouldn't give you you know what I mean
like you could pay a priest and he'd
[__] do rituals and [__] like that
and have girls [__] smoking smoking
and blowing smoke dancing actually kind
of fun you know the rituals they're not
it's not Sinister or anything you know
to usually is to help you with money yes
it's usually with and job and to keep
your boss from firing you [__] like that
you yeah just regular people concerns
yeah now you got to pay the priest you
know that's usually the offerings you
know might be you know money usually is
what it is then they might tell you that
you had to put an offering out you know
on the streets or [__] cigarettes and
a a dead chicken you know yeah it's
usually a dead chicken money some booze
yeah booze might be a watch or something
like that something for the spirits so
whatever spirit is you're dealing with
and you got to and then you leave it out
on a busy street with candles burning
and there Brazil has a lot of poor
people in it and that [__] will sit
there untouched
they won't touch that yet because that
was an offering yeah and they respect SC
that right yeah
so something
like Narco soldiers or people involved
in heavy duty organized crime they got
to do hardcore [__] to keep things
together including commit
murders because they're trying to seek
protection from the law so they don't
get caught right and they'll appeal to
Demons or whatever mhm so you're going
to going to have
people try to make money and get power
off that yep and you know evil priests
basically and they're out there I think
Mexico right now their main one is a
Sant Muerte you know s the saint of
death kind of like the Grim Reaper and a
lot of your Narco agents are give
offerings to that one it sounds crazy in
North America but because you know for
us Christianity is mostly some kind of a
protestantism you you know like I'm
Southern Baptist by tradition you know
and we don't have systems of saints and
things we have some of our [__] weird
rituals you know
[__] dancing with snakes and drinking
poison and [__] but all that stuff is
kind of that's pretty fringe that's
pretty fringe but you know there there
there is that kind of [__] every now and
then but um
Catholicism opens up opportunities for
an extended universe or expanded
universe in religion so and it it's very
uh
useful and of course Mexico is a
synthesis of Catholicism and Mayan
Traditions Aztec traditions and stuff
and if you really study the
Kista where hernand Cortez and Spain you
know they kind of merged kind of took
over and kind of merged with
Mexico the Spanish monks of the time
noticed
that Aztec religions and Mayan beliefs
had a lot of crossover with Catholicism
that everything that the Mayans believed
in there was a Catholic analog yeah
pretty much so it helped conversion to
Catholicism
because uh you know the the Mayans
recognized it the AZ text went oh yeah
yeah we know what that is so there there
isn't a big difference difference really
between I the whole the whole Catholic
thing of appealing to Saints for
particular things for help with
particular things um that was very
familiar um to indigenous people when
you know the Spaniards came here so it
and you know all the you know things
like Santa Ria and the religion that
we're talking about um in this
particular case which was um Palo
mambe was um an a kind of an African
religion that got brought to the
Caribbean through Cuba and stuff like
that like with the slave trade and so a
lot of the slaves didn't really find
Catholicism that different so it's very
easy for them to like be like hey yeah
we totally converted to Catholicism but
they were still like doing stuff with
their with their um traditional Gods the
one I used to go to was was makumba Al
there also condom blé is like another
word it was another division of it and
it was it was African African
Catholicism
um it was very cool kind of like
something at that time you know it' be
hard it it was hard for an American to
see something like that you had to have
friends it would take you and you know
I'd give money when I went to it and it
was in dude's backyard it was all
enclosed but it very serious um girls
dancing they're dressed in kind of like
uh a traditional garb from Baya which is
kind of like white bonnets and big long
skirts with and it's kind of the it's
the way Brazilian Africans dressed and
they're out there dancing and blowing
smoke and stuff and they could be of any
race they're just Brazilians you know
they don't have to be African but the
the beliefs are
African mixed with Catholicism and other
stuff uh but I thought it was great you
know
now some of the stuff that the Narco
agents are doing I'm going to call them
that because they come in a lot of
different forms you know um
it's Catholic adjacent but it's the dark
side they're dealing with
demons but the Mayans and the Aztecs
dealt with demons that was part of their
religion um the the the Spaniards called
it like it was human sacrifice and they
called it demon worship but that was
just the the the
Spanish concept of it that was their
view of
it the the minds and the atics didn't
really worship demons and Devils what
they did is they tried to bribe them off
they were scared of them so they would
try to pay off the devil to keep them
away yeah to keep him from [__] with
them that's what they were doing here
have some cigarettes and whiskey please
leave me alone and they would uh provide
human sacrifices sacrifice of children
virgin women uh old people just
anybody sometimes fully grown people the
best ones they could find they they'd
sacrifice them maybe to ward off evil
pay off and bribe Devils or to bribe say
like a rain goddess to Make It Rain you
know so there wasn't any kind of like
malice in the hearts of these people
they actually believed these things that
they were trying to save themselves from
disaster you know the the uh by all
accounts of Spanish monks that were
doing the conversion we trying to save a
lot of May literature and Aztec
religions and stuff for posterity cuz
they said it was really well written but
the Catholic Church [__] was wasn't
having any of it they just considered
everything be devil worship really but
the guys that were at on site kind of
knew it for what it really
was they said that the uh that the
Aztecs were good people you know that it
was just they were doing this out of
religious
piety well when the narcos got involved
in all this [__] of course it's kind of
like in their Traditions now like cuz
sacrificing people you know and some of
the sacrifices were pretty brutal uh in
in Aztec times some of it involved just
Kings punishing people cutting their
fingertips off and [__] like that you
know C capturing enemies and warfare for
them wasn't killing enemies it was
capturing them so you could sacrifice
them up on top of a temple to repay the
blood debt and the blood debt had to be
repaid so the sun would continue to rise
and set you know every day they they're
trying to keep the Clockwork of the
[__] Universe running it was a very
apparently really did believe that yeah
well and the thing about this particular
cult I do think it I mean it does seem
from their
actions that most of the
followers did actually
believe this yeah now the head of the
cult who we're going to be talking about
Alonso Ganzo did he believe it
entirely I don't think so but I don't
know there's a couple things that he did
that made me think that maybe not but he
could but I don't know he could have
been a Believer as well because he was
raised in the [__] so I'm not really
sure but a couple of his things that he
did like kind of made me think that he
knew and by the same token seemingly as
Tech and Mayan rulers in charge of their
city
states they probably believed it in
general but they also used it as a tool
of control and oppression cuz once you
have the power to make people pay the
blood debt by [__] sacrificing them
you could keep them in line you say if
you don't listen to me I'm going
sacrifice your daughter make her pay the
blood debt so they were doing [__] like
that they probably believed what they
were doing worked but they also used it
as a tool yeah I think that's a good way
of putting it because I think that's
pretty much exactly what was going on
here yeah by all accounts um many of the
people that were in this cult did
believe that what they were doing was
working because it did seem to work but
I think there were other reasons that it
was working not because of the magic but
they really did seem to believe it
whether he believed it or not I'm not
entirely certain I think he believed it
to an extent but I don't know if he had
as much faith in it as the followers did
a lot of Mayan and Aztec sacrifice Human
Sacrifice really if you got when you
really looked down to the base of the
root cause of it is because they didn't
know why crops failed they knew if it
didn't rent
the crops would fail but they couldn't
understand why crops were failing
because they didn't understand about
fertilization at the time and they would
deplete the soil around the
city so they couldn't feed everybody
because the each yield would get worse
so they would sacrifice people they
couldn't feed them anyway tried trying
to make the population fit the food
supply they had they thought well maybe
God wants us to get rid of all these
many people because we're in debt to him
and if we get rid of this many people
we'll be able to eat you know it was
just the way they rationalized things
they didn't know about
fertilization that would have prevented
a lot of it but if you were to probably
explained that to an Aztec or a mine of
the time the concept of fertilization
probably would have blown their mind
they probably wouldn't have believed it
it' have been hell what the [__] you
talking about all these people being
born every time somebody's born it takes
blood from God they're giving us the
blood so we no sapping god of the blood
that he needs we got to give it back
we're in debt that's what they're
doing so it'd be real hard to if you're
born with those belief system it'd be
real hard to reason with them uh but
it's fascinating it's just part of thing
of [__] meso America and Central and
South America they mostly Central
America they've in
some there's something in the Indigenous
people where this is kind of a
traditional thinking for them you know
me Catholicism [__] goes right along
with it it played right into it yeah Zan
said you guys did a show on Santa morte
I thought we had I knew there was I knew
we had done something similar to this
yeah we did do a show on Santa morte but
this guy's [__] was even darker than
that yeah this is way way worse than
Santa morte [__] this is way worse oh I
got way behind Okay um yeah Cas Lee said
azex were trying to stop the end of the
world by sacrificing humans by the
hundreds right Long Count was part of
the problem too yeah the Long Count yeah
Zan said I feel like constanzo was way
more into the sacrifice and religious
aspect that he was into selling drugs
yeah because it almost seemed like the
whole drug thing was just like a
sideline he wasn't even into drugs and
there was a thing in his cult where if
you got caught doing drugs he would [__]
you up like cuz he actually killed some
of his own followers for like being
caught doing that he was just very they
were just selling it I guess like to
make money or whatever so you know what
I mean yeah and Z said from what I
remember a c Sals came to him for
protection yeah they did that's how he
made a lot of his money which we'll get
into in a bit
yeah so that's why and the thing about
it is that and this is kind of true all
over the world but people that are
engaged in very very risky professions
whether they're illegal or not tend to
be more superstitious because their
lives are more uncertain so they want
something that gives them some certainty
so if you are in a drug cartel and you
are afraid you're going to get shot up
or captured or whatever like at any
moment then that that's kind of a very
uncertain existence so it stands to
reason that those people would be
largely very very superstitious and are
kind of looking for anything that's
going to give them a leg up even if it's
just you know even if it's just to us
seems like magic [__] but they
really really do believe it
though um let's see yeah astrology yeah
because Eric Lyn said they knew a lot of
astrology use that as a tool I think the
Aztec yeah yeah yeah um Okay so
so let me see okay all right so do you
want to kind of get into this and you
can you can kind of throw in your your
two cents like whenever we get into this
like I
said this cult once it was discovered I
feel like it wasn't really discovered by
The World At Large until
1989 which is when uh the Mark killroy
Case happen um but they had been doing
this for several years prior it was just
kind of more on the down low
so when the story came
out they you know the media had a
[__] field day with it because like I
said this was the late ' 80s and they
were still all about satanic Panic so
they were just kind of like there you
know the Narco Satanist the this that
and the other thing which like I said
they're not technically they're not
Satanist but it was kind of a similar
thing so I could see why they said that
but they did kind of like blow the [__]
well I don't want to say they blew the
[__] out of proportion because it was
bad enough as it was but it's like they
speculated about a lot of stuff that
they didn't really know about so there's
that and I kind of feel like too because
the religions of santoria poo mayom
mayom and stuff like that are not that
familiar to Americans um particularly
back then they would have seen it as
Satanism because they didn't understand
it I suppose but there are lots of
people that practice those religions
that don't do this [__] this was just a
a super outlier you know what I mean now
as far as they know and we're going to
talk about them well you know like I
said you have to know the SP any
religion can be taken to its logical
extreme and um that happens quite often
and it happens quite often like but it's
usually like a fringe that's doing that
kind Stones type [__] right most of the
people that follow particular religions
are completely you know harmless and
stuff like I said I don't really truck
with religions I don't see the point of
them but a lot of people most people
that follow them it's just like nothing
but some people
like these people um kind of take the
[__] and uh go crazy with it let's let's
call it that
now they're not entirely sure like I
said how many people this cult killed
Wikipedia says the official the
confirmed number is 15 but many more
suspected I've also seen 16 confirmed
I've seen 17 confirmed and some people
think like it's dozens more that they're
not that they can't really prove you
know what I mean I would suspect it's a
lot more considering what their um what
their um methods were uh I bet there was
a lot of people that they killed that
they didn't know about which like I said
I'll get into in a little bit so let's
kind of talk about the leader of this
cult as it would become
adalo De Jesus Conan yeah now I think on
the on the teaser picture I think I put
Alfonso instead of ad alfo I don't know
why I put that but I fixed it on the
other thing but I was just kind of cuz I
looked at my YouTube thing and I was
like oh [__] I put Alfonso on that I had
to change it like right before the show
cuz I don't know what I was thinking but
his name's adalo like Adolf you know
what I mean now he was actually born in
Miami so he was born in 1962 now Florida
man yeah he's Florida man which that
that totally Florida man toally satanic
cult Mexico kills 14 15 and probably
more like something probably more yeah
it's Flor man now his mom whose name was
dilia um she was actually a Cuban
immigrant Cuban Cuban Refugee now she
had a doo when she was only 15 years
old now she would eventually end up
having three kids all of them by
different fathers I believe two of her
husbands died which I don't know if
that's suspicious or not but like we'll
get into that now after her first
husband died she moved to uh San Juan
Puerto Rico
um and then got remarried like met
someone else and remarried there now
deia the mom and Ado's grandmother were
both santoria
priestesses now adalo was actually
baptized Catholic um and you know was
even an alter boy and everything like
that but just like we were saying
Catholicism has this whole extended
universe so even though he was baptized
as a Catholic he would also go with his
mom on trips to Haiti and learn about
Voodoo now according to some sources
that I found ad ala's mother took him to
like a Haitian priest like when he was
still a baby pretty much and this priest
allegedly said that this kid is a chosen
one and he's going to do great things
and I was just kind of like depends on
your definition of great I guess but
okay he was a great monster I
suppose so as we were talking about
before santoria much like voodoo
is you know a religion that came from
Africa with the slave trade and kind of
Blends Catholicism in with African what
what you want to call like folk yeah
essentially voodo um all of them are
different but they're similar you know
what I mean so as we mentioned like
there'll be different deities that you
ask for particular things and or you
know if they're Bad deities that'll [__]
you up you give them things to kind of
saave them off that that's another kind
of thing usually it's food or booze or
cigarettes that's another big one or you
know a ritual sacrifice but it's almost
always an animal usually a chicken
usually priest could eat yeah yeah
exactly yeah cuz they eat the sacrifices
but they're not going to say that but a
lot of times they do well yeah I mean
don't waste it it's meat yeah but you
know so they actually moved back to him
you know constanzo and his family
actually moved back to Miami in 1972
because his dad was uh sick at this
point and he moved back to get treatment
but his stepdad died not too long after
that now his stepdad at this point was
kind of he wasn't wealthy but he was
like okay like he was comfortable I
guess if you want to put it that way so
when he died he left the family some
money so they were kind of like now in
the middle
class now when adula was a
teenager he was kind of um cuz his mom
was roll into Santa and everything like
so he was raised in that belief system
so when he was a teenager he got a out
to like a priest a sorcerer type thing
and at this point he started practicing
uh Pao mayombe which is again kind of
similar religion to santoria um you know
and involves animal sacrifice and making
offerings to gods and things like that
now deia his mom she remarried you know
yet again at this point and the new
stepdad was uh real into Pao mambe and
ALS also was a drug dealer so there was
that now one big thing and this will um
Factor largely into the story going
forward one of the big things in Palo
mambe you make offerings to the Gods in
this pot it's a cauldron like which is a
ceremonial cauldron and this is called
an
inanga now in this you put anything
that's like consecrated like bones or
sticks or body parts or anything like
that they usually will put animal stuff
in there um but there's also kind of a
tradition of like grave robbing like
digging up old bones from cemeteries and
stuff and putting them in there like
that the thing about the anganga is that
it's almost treated as though and I
think it's perceived by
Believers as almost a living entity so
like whatever you put in there um kind
of either strengthens it or makes it
smarter or whatever like it's like it's
the god itself you know what I'm saying
so it's like for example if you were
like oh I'm doing a spell where I need
strength or I feel like my anganga needs
strength then you would if you were on
the bad side of this belief system then
you would go kill like a strong person
and like put his muscles in there like
that kind of [__] you know what I mean
or it's just like oh well want something
to do with like youth or I want youth
then they'll kill a kid and put this put
his [__] in there you know what I mean
so it's that kind of stuff but it's kind
of considered like a living being sort
of and you feed it like whatever you
think it needs at any particular time
which like I said this is going to come
back later on because yeah a lot of a
lot of problems arose because of this
kind of thing this this
pot now so in Miami while they were in
Miami in the 70s the neighbors of the
family um
would kind of notice stuff like dead
animals being left on their doorsteps
and stuff like that like if you know if
if they had like any kind of dispute any
kind of beef with the constanzo family
suddenly you have all these dead animals
like showing up at your [__] on your
[__] doorstep you know what I mean
because they were putting curses on
people essentially what they were doing
now his mom she later got arrested for
many things but she what of the things
she was arrested for was she had like 27
animals in her house they said they went
in the house and there was just like
[__] and blood like all over the [__]
place she wasn't much of a housekeeper
is what I'm saying which is kind of
interesting because adula they always
said like even from like a really young
child he was almost like a super neat
freak like almost like OCD level like he
was always like super clean and and I
wonder I don't know though it's like cuz
I kind of thought that was maybe a
reaction to like growing up in like
filth and like just houses that were had
blood and feces all over the [__]
walls but they said he was kind of like
that when he was little too so I'm not
really
sure um now his mom and adalo were also
arrested like later on a bunch of times
for stealing stuff vandalism shoplifting
that kind of thing now according to his
mom deia uh supposedly his psychic
powers were supposedly getting better
and better around this time too some of
the things that he supposedly predicted
he supposedly predicted um that Ronald
Reagan would get shot but that he would
survive which happened in 1980 obviously
um he also allegedly predicted that big
um earthquake that happened in Mexico
City in
1985 um you know but like I said people
are talking about that after the fact so
I'm kind of assuming that that's
probably [__] you can just yeah I
totally predicted that yeah you can't
prove that he said that before right
that's what I'm saying like it's not
like he wrote it down and put an
envelope and mailed it to it's like it
was in a safety deposit or some [__]
like that you know what I mean it was
just oh yeah he totally predicted that I
was the only person there but he told me
that that was totally sounds like what
is called an apocryphal tale it does
[Laughter]
yeah it does uh also he could again
allegedly astral project okay and could
heal sick people so you
know now because constanzo was you know
fairly good-look
dude um he actually worked as a model
for a little while and it's not he
wasn't like a big deal or anything like
that but he did get some modeling work
there are some a couple of pictures of
him around how old was he during this
time um he was like late teens okay yeah
I
believe um sort have died yeah I was a
model in Brazil did you did I tell you
about that no you didn't tell me you did
a commercial you never told me that two
ice cream commercials you never told me
that ever how could you not tell me that
cuz it was just normal [__] that I did I
had two ice cream commercials man I'm
finding out all kind of [__] there's all
kind of [__] that you never told it was
called keone ice cream you never told me
that yeah I had chasing a girl chased a
girl I went to school with down the
[__] we we we did the [__] at graded
at graded High School where we went
International High School I chased a
Brazilian model down to
D High School when everybody else was in
class but they're filming it and and
gave her an ice cream that's basically
it I said something he's like here I'm
not stalking you I'm just getting you
ice cream I promise hand her I'm not
going to kill you it's fine yeah it was
like a [__] like a for second
commercial oh my God I wonder if we
could find that somewhere yeah probably
not keep on ice cream commercial oh my
God somebody somebody go look on YouTube
[__] on the way back
1986 all right I'm going to look for
that I can't believe you never told me
that6 or 87 I can't believe you never
told me that yeah s always finding out
like new F they had two different edits
fascinating new facts they it was one
commercial but they had two different
edits of it oh okay I'm gonna find that
[__] I was I was pretty as [__]
somebody's got to have that somewhere
yeah I'll find it um but yeah okay
so so yeah so he did some modeling work
like I said it wasn't a huge deal or
anything like that but um but he moved
to Mexico City in 1984 they may have not
have used it though yeah maybe not
because I don't ever remember seeing it
oh you never saw okay remember but I
didn't watch television oh okay so I'll
I'll see if it's WR I saw the Final Cut
just spell the ice cream they show they
showed me the Final Cut they recruited
me from the drama program at a great at
gr at school right I had to do some
voiceover work from them but when I was
doing the voiceover work I had to
translate some of their other
commercials into English an English dub
they were taking that to Europe though
okay and they showed me the edit of the
little thing like I said just spell the
ice cream brand for me and I'll keep k i
b o n k i b o okay easy just like just
like I think it was Ki it might have
been qu B that's see that's what I was
thinking I was thinking it might have
been keone I was thinking probably q b m
but yeah
so uh so yeah so he moves to Mexico City
in 1984 now while he's there he starts
doing
like essentially becoming a dude that
sells spells and like magical cleansings
and stuff like that to people now he
actually got in eventually with selling
these spells to kind of people that were
up in you know the elite now I don't
know if this was the first thing I think
this was the first thing that got him
into it but he was approached by a guy I
can't remember what his name was but he
was like a like a pretty popular singer
like a pop star and his career was a
little bit on the decline right and he
was kind of looking to revive his career
so he came to him you know to do some
spells to like help him out or whatever
and the guy and uh adalo says hey I'll
help you out for free if you introduce
me to a bunch of celebrities so
apparently that happened so he
eventually got in with so he got
connections at that point with like you
know famous like actors and [__] like
that and started doing stuff for them
and then that kind of extended to other
Elite people like politicians and
whatever so people started coming to him
and it seems like and like I said I'm
not entirely sure like how this happened
but it does seem like a lot of the
Spells he did worked or people perceived
that they worked so he started getting
like a reputation it was like oh this
[__] is like he he's really like the
real thing you know what I mean like his
[__] really works so he kind of his name
started getting around so he did kind of
have that now after that like when his
name started getting around as we
mentioned before people who were in
criminal
Enterprises tend to be more
superstitious than maybe your
run-of-the-mill
person and particularly members of drug
cartels uh were very superstitious and
were always like looking for something
that would protect them from the police
or like keep them from getting caught so
as adolfo's name was getting around he
started getting approached by members of
drug cartels who were seeking his spells
like for protection against the police
they they wanted to be bulletproof and
all this other kind of crap and I think
that the Haitian priest that had you
know told him he was going to be a
chosen one or whatever I think he also
did that too like he also so I think
there was like a connection there as
well so the rituals you know always uh
they always had animal sacrifices right
but the price had to do with what kind
of animal was sacrificed which I guess
makes sense right you get like chickens
which is kind of your run of the M thing
because every you know it's chickens
everywhere um you know then you'd kind
of go up to goats then maybe like a boa
constrictor which was significantly more
expensive then he was even sacrificing
kind of more exotic anims like zebras
and [__] damn I don't know where the
[__] he was getting those and he even
did like lion cubs which I think was the
most exp he didn't into a full he didn't
into a full siiz lion because assho that
would be really stupid yeah it's just
kind of like those are exotic animals
man yeah I don't know where he was
getting from he was getting from
somewhere but they were super super
expensive drug dealers yeah we got them
here got them here got them up the
street here we do yeah got a guy down
there that's [__] breeding breeding
lions and giraffes and zebras but he the
international sellers you can't see it
he's got a huge [__] wall around it
yeah well he doesn't want my mom knows
him though she dealt with him a long
time ago did business with him he's nice
he was in some kind of Tarzan movie I
think he played a Tarzan okay it's one
of the Tarzan one of the Tarzan he's an
old man now yeah yeah I guess they would
be yeah but yeah so as he got up in the
cartels and everything like I said he
also got in with um a bunch of corrupt
cops which is Mr 88 said before what do
you call a corrupt Mexican cop a cop
yeah pretty I mean pretty much so um you
know that's not entirely the case
because one of them that came in like
afterward that you know that after
constanza was doing all this crap like
did actually want to crack down on them
but for a long time they got away with a
bunch of [__] because he had police
connections you know what I mean so
that's why and a lot of the police were
helping the drug cartels too like CU I'm
sure they were cutting him off all a
piece of the money now this particular
cult probably in with the the gulf
cartel uh maybe among others not really
sure but yeah he kind of knew everybody
and like I said he had a reputation for
being
good at what he did which was ritual
sacrifices that would get you like magic
[__] that you wanted and I guess people
were happy with his Services because he
was he became like quite wealthy from it
now another thing about constanzo uh and
I think that s might have brought this
up early earlier that he was uh this guy
was the definition of sexually ambiguous
yeah um this dude was it's weird because
like a lot of the documentaries us
called him gay um I think that he was
bisexual and he was kind of like the
very definition of bisexual he did seem
to have more bought some [__] and he
became sexual well no what I was saying
is that he did seem to have more
meaningful relationships or long-term
relationships with men but not
necessarily um you know he did have like
a lot of relationships with women too so
I think he was almost kind of like like
completely bisexual this must been where
they got the inspiration for the
character out of [__] confessions of
a trick baby part
two remember that movie that we saw yeah
in that case he was transsexual doing
all this right but it sounds like this
is where they got the idea maybe um
there was kill a bunch of people too
there actually was a movie made Loosely
based on this I think it's called
Borderland it's a horror movie obviously
it's how could it be anything else I
think it came out in
2007 I've seen it but it was a long time
ago IC yeah it's all melted um yeah yeah
so like I said it does seem like most of
his long-term lovers were men but he did
have um you know Sarah aldr who we'll
talk about in a bit uh who seemed to be
with him for a long time who he seemed
to have some fondness more I'm not
really sure what that relationship was
like um also I should note that he had
uh at least well several relationships
with women because they as far as they
know he fathered at least two children
with two different women and possibly
more now I think that the first one of
those if I'm not mistaken happened when
he was a teenager I think he was only 14
and I think he impregnated his
13-year-old girlfriend and they had a
baby and then I think like later on his
teenage years I think he knocked up
another girl like I said I don't think
that he had any contact with those kids
going forward but he did have sexual
relationships with women and it did
Father at least two as far as I know but
it could be like more than that I don't
think the kids ever factored into his
life in any great
way now so he
starts um several of the
male lovers that he recruited at first
like that were kind of in on the ground
floor of the cult if you want to call it
that um and they also kind of helped him
out with his spellcasting business uh
these three guys were named Martin
Quintana Jorge Montes and Omar
Ora now over time these three and
eventually everybody in this cult would
start referring ing to constanzo as El
padrino padrino The Godfather that's
what they started calling
him so at this stage adalo he's getting
kind of wealthy he's getting a
reputation and he's getting a little big
for his Bridges let's call it that so
because he started to think that his
spells were responsible for you know big
cartel's success he's like you you know
my spells are the reasons you guys
didn't get caught and you're making all
this money and blahy blah so one of the
things he decided that he was going to
do cuz he wanted to make some more money
cuz he was making a lot of money but not
as much as the cartels he's like I'm
going to make cartel [__] money right
so he goes to one of the most powerful
families that he was acquainted with
that had come to him who were called the
kadas now probably stupidly he pretty
much just goes right to their compound
or whatever and essentially demands
50% of their [__] or I'm not or I'm
going to like curse you or blah blah s
that to a cartel yeah he's got some
serious balls on him yeah or or he's
real stupid I mean it could be it could
be might be both and I mean he's real
young I mean you have to think this dude
spoiler alert when he died he was I
believe 26 years old yeah so all of this
stuff is happening when he's like in his
early 20s when everyone is an idiot you
know what I mean he might have been a
good judge of character he looked at the
head of the little cartel and he went a
this fucker's a he's you know he's a
sucker maybe you know what I mean it
could be he scared he might have sensed
fear in him and went okay I got
him get know yeah Zan said the
documentary I sent Jenny literally
showed them digging up the bodies it was
disgusting yeah it was pretty gross um
like it's
not I don't know it was pretty gross I I
could watch it but it it was pretty
gross so it's you know if you're
sensitive to like seeing actual bodies
being dug up and actual [__] they were
digging it up with the what do you call
that thing the thing that digs up dirt
the thing that digs dirt steam shovel
well bulldozer yeah that's what I was
that was the word I was trying to think
of I know that word I just couldn't
think you I was like you know the the
dirt the dirt Diggy thing the dirt thing
the dirt Diggy thing yeah sucks getting
old I'm telling you my brain's getting
like swiss cheese I can't remember words
anymore but yeah so he just basically
marches in in there and says I want half
your money like I want to be a he wanted
to be like a full business partner he's
like cuz I I you know my spells helped
you out with your [__] and like you
didn't get caught and you're making all
this money I want you to cut me off a
piece of that but half of it so um the
kadas are like No And um worse than that
one of the bodyguards I think like as he
was leaving the compound like laughed at
him you know what I mean so at this
point uh adalo is just kind of like yeah
no that's not going to stand so guess
what
happened not too long after this seven
members of the family or seven members
of the compound some of them weren't
related some were employees mysteriously
disappeared hm I wonder where they could
have
gone later on uh their bodies were found
I believe they were dredged out of a
river and they had clearly
been uh
tortured they had their fingers and toes
missing their ears were missing uh their
genitals had been cut off uh a couple of
their brains were missing one of the
bodies even had the spine
removed apparently um the young girl she
was a she was a maid of the family and
she was like a teenager she had her
heart cut
out now it turned out later reportedly
like after they caught him and all this
stuff came out that what had happened
was that he had lured the members of the
family to the location by saying man I
feel really bad about coming to your
place and getting in this big fight with
you cuz I was wanting half your money
like I must have been possessed by a
demon and I maybe infected you guys with
this demon and I will give you a free
cleansing to show how sorry I am right
so all of them were like Okay sounds
legit and they went to this place I mean
Fu up let me kill you they were
suspicious um but evidently what
happened like they get there you know
they brought bodyguards and everything
they get there and they have the room
like all set up like it was going to be
a cleansing where there's candles and
all kind of [__] like it like it was
supposed to look so he comes in there
and castano is all apologetic and man
I'm so sorry I must been possessed or
whatever and then one of his henchmen
comes in and just [__] blows them all
away
damn so that's apparently what happened
and then and then they mutilated them
and dumped them in [__] River so all
the torture stuff was done post
postmortem as far as I know
um like I said a lot of this a lot of
the [__] that came out about it is just
from various cult members that admitted
[__] to police so I don't know how
accurate a lot of it is because they
didn't find out about this stuff until
afterward until like after 1989 you know
what I mean yeah so they could be making
[__] up or not remembering [__] right or
whatever cuz no one was there that you
know and constanso is dead so and he
would have probably never confessed
anyways so yeah so everybody got blown
away and then they all got cut up and
stuff I don't know like I said I don't
know if he tied them up and tortured
them first cuz oh that'll come later
just wait now also around this time um
possibly because now he had killed all
this members of this powerful cartel
family the
C now one family that he did kind of
know of who were kind of smaller time
drug dealers but he kind of wanted to
get in he wanted to get in with a Big
Cartel family so we could make more
money right that's what he was trying to
do so to that end he starts he takes up
with this college student by the name of
Sarah
aldr now she was a very tall girl she
was 6' one she very striking uh quite a
quite a good-look woman now eventually
over time uh she would become his second
in command uh she would eventually be
known as La Madrina the
Godmother now Sarah was born in 1964 she
grew up in a regular normal ass middle
class family in Matamoros in Mexico
which is right near the border of with
Texas um and she actually went to high
school and college in Brownsville Texas
right across the
bridge now when she was a college
student everybody said she was a
delightful delightful person straight A
student she was a cheerleader um but on
the other side of that she was also
super interested in the occult and
because of um some like a family
connection through somebody she dated in
school um she kind of knew a lot about
drug cartels the weird thing about it is
that she seemed to have been completely
living a double life like when she was
in Texas like in college and stuff she
was just like straight a cheerleader
college student but when she would go
over the border to Mexico it was all
about a cult and drug dealing you know
what I mean it's not that uncommon
people didn't know like people didn't
seem to know that's not that uncommon
rings of female
assassins Mexican cartel assassins
they're female and they have weird
initiation rights where they're
necrofilia where they have sex with the
dead victims and all kinds of weird [__]
bathing in blood count as bathy [__] and
they're young late teens early 20s
evidently hotties too I don't know if
they all survived the ones I was
thinking of somebody might be able to
drop in the comment section what ring
ring of girls I was talking I think
there was like four or five of them and
I think they were all killed eventually
by the Mexican Army but they killed
[__] dozens and dozens of other Cel
members and stuff they were
assassins cuz who is who's going to
suspect you know hot chick of being an
assassin you know yeah I mean they try
to pick these dudes up and then they
[__] bring them into a Kill Zone and
[__] murder them it's un and they
were like to to initiate the new girls
they had to have sex with the dude that
they killed after he was dead you in a
bathtub cuz then they'd have something
to hold over yeah there's some well and
you know they were witches yeah you know
well that's kind of what this chick was
too yeah and like I said I mean we'll
get into talking about her in a bit but
um she was by all accounts um was
interested in the occult before she
hooked up with this dude um she tried to
say later that you know he forced her
and blahy blah I don't think that's the
case I don't think that's the case I
think she loved this [__] she seemed to
um K Lee says you guys watch the
documentary series Terror in the jungle
it's a mindblowing documentary on
Jonestown suicides o I don't think I've
seen that yet I've seen I've seen a lot
of documentaries about that though like
one of the worst ones that I saw was
almost all footage that they took what
the [__] was that called I can't
remember what it I think I I saw it in a
theater like a long time that was one of
the most depressing [__] things yeah
it's old yeah it's old yeah I saw it
back in the early 2000s or mid 2000s or
something like that
like at an indie
theater but yeah so here's this chick
right now how okay so how this all came
about like I said um constanzo was
trying to get in with a cartel family
and one of the cartel families that he
kind of had connections with that
weren't huge but they were still you
know smalltime drug dealers were the
Hernandez
family now what happened was that Sarah
ALR she went to college with a guy named
sarapen Hernandez
Garcia and his uncle like she dated his
uncle his name was Elio Hernandez
Rivera and they were marijuana
Smugglers um you know like a ton per
week is what they uh estimate so not I
mean not huge big time but like you know
kind of on the on the middle scale of
like drug dealers right yeah so she was
dating this guy that was kind of like a
mid tier drug
dealer now this whole family Enterprise
the head of it at this time um in the
mid 80s was Saul Hernandez Rivera who
was Elio's older brother so Elio was the
one that was dating Sarah ELR now he got
assassinated in
1987 and then at that point there was
all kind of like the family was all
fighting and everything like CU they
were all like jocking for position right
but Elio actually turned out to be the
new head of the firm of the
establishment or whatever and he went to
constanzo to get spells and stuff like
that for you know for protection and
power and stuff like that so Sarah
apparently was also there like his at
his initiation
ceremony now as time went
on all of the members of the Hernandez
family/ drug dealing gang cartel they
started Ed kind of getting more under
the power of constanzo and his cult
beliefs um you know because he would do
sacrifices for them like ritual animal
sacrifices and it would appear to work
like they just kept getting away with
[__] and they didn't get caught and they
just were really thinking that he was
the man you know what I mean so like as
the longer that went on like the more he
was the more power he was able to have
over them and they actually absolutely
believed that he had magic powers I mean
it really does seem that they really did
believe that the thing about Sarah ALR
that's kind of
interesting um later on like after this
whole cult was exposed they thought that
maybe because she was so striking she
was so tall and she was very pretty um
that she was probably used to lure more
people into the cult um love bombing
right yeah they think that maybe that
was one of her main roles um she did
allegedly uh participate in some of the
stuff but I don't know how but she knew
was going on for sure even though later
she said she didn't I don't know how
handson she was with some of the [__]
that was going on later but she for sure
knew what was going on even though later
she said she didn't know anything about
it like one of the things she would do
and I thought this was kind of
interesting because we' reviewed this
movie so apparently her favorite movie
in the [__] world was the Believers
that 1987 movie with Martin Sheen in it
which one was that that was the one
about the Santa Ria I think it was Santa
Ria cult in New York City and like all
those people were turning up dead like
we reviewed it not to it's a good movie
I really like it remember that one she
loved that movie and she kind of seems
to have used it as a recruiting tool
like apparent and people that she would
bring into the fold like they would
watch it like over and over and over
almost like she was trying to like
convert them like by showing them this
movie even though the movie was like
fairly accurate in some ways but but you
know it was kind of overated in way she
wanteded to see that because she's
showing these new people that what
they're doing is [__] known about and
elevated by Hollywood production yeah so
she's you know it is glamorizing it yeah
I think that's kind of what yeah yeah so
uh so yeah so she would show this movie
to people that she was kind of
supposedly trying to get into the
culture trying to like show her
religious beliefs um it's weird because
she seemed to be studying in college she
was studying physical education I think
she wanted to be like a teacher yeah um
and like I said students at the school
thought she was totally totally normal
but then she was doing all this
stuff like when she would go to Mexico
um you know and actually it it was so
bad that later on like after they all
got caught like investigators thought
maybe she had like multiple personality
disorder or something like that like she
but I think she was just able to like
compartmentalize but yeah she's still
alive nowadays as far as I know a lot of
the other ones aren't she's only a
couple years older than me yeah she's
pretty
young so constanzo um you know ad Alo
constanzo and his followers at this
point I'm not sure how many he had but
it was quite a few so they set up their
little base of operations at a place
called Rancho Santa Elena now this was
near Matamoros I believe it's about 20
miles outside of kind of the you know
downtown of monam Morris if you want to
call it that now this property had been
owned by the Hernandez
family now at this
stage prior to this it seems like they
had mostly been doing the rituals and
sacrificing
animals but it seems at this point I
mean it's possible that they could have
murdered people before this I'm not
really sure but it seems like right
around this time that the cult decided
that that you know we can put all these
animals and like you know bones that we
rob from Graves and stuff like that into
the inanga the you know the ceremonial
cauldron and that's cool it seems to be
working and everything but wouldn't it
be much better and like give us much
more power much more strength and stuff
like that if we sacrificed live humans
instead of just
animals now so they got this idea
so over the next you know short period
of time a bunch of mutilated bodies
started turning up around Mexico's
City now one of these people who was
murdered um and this was believed to
be the first brain that was inserted
into the inanga the first human brain
anyway they would put animal brains and
stuff in there because if you like I
said said the anganga is kind of like a
a thing like a like a being and so if
you want it to think you have to put a
brain in it right I mean makes sense so
they had put animal brains and stuff
like that but as far as I know as far as
my research took me the first human
brain that was put in there was from um
a transvesti that one of them knew like
she lived in the same building as one of
his followers and the followers like man
like she's such a pain in the ass she's
always like in the hallway like
smooching on underage boys and like
blocking the stairs and blah blah and so
he was like she's a pain in the ass and
then so adala was like well do you want
me to like take care of her and he
didn't say
no so consan was like okay well maybe
we'll do that so they go to her
apartment and basically tired her to a
chair um cut off her fingers and toes
cut off off her ears cut off the
penis and then um they were like well
now we better kill her because she's
screaming her hat off obviously and you
know the neighbors are going to call the
cops which they did it while she was
alive yeah they did all this while yeah
wow they're like we need the brain to
put in the anganga because the the
anganga needs to think we need a brain
so they cut off the top of the skull and
um popped the brain out while he was
alive and took it yeah damn and so
could well I mean you know I'm sure she
wasn't alive like while they were doing
it I mean you know what I mean but
cutting off the toes and fingers and
ears and stuff well the reason that they
did that was because you could stay
alive longer I mean you're not going to
die from getting a finger cut off or a
toe cut off or even your penis cut off
that's a lot of blood loss but it's like
they kind I think they kind of did it
slowly damn but they needed a brain so
they took the brain damn and how' they
cut the top of the head off did they say
uh probably machete that's what they
usually use okay that would have killed
him yeah yeah that's what I'm saying
yeah well obviously if you're going to
do that they're just like yeah we need
to bring there's a way to cut it off and
keep them alive well yeah but I don't
think little circular but they were just
like in an apartment building I'm sure
they didn't really want to go too crazy
with it and like I said they were
screaming and
everything so they kind of cut up the
body and put it in bags and stuff and
just like threw them in you know garbage
cans like around the city and stuff like
that so as I said at this point once
they decided that man human sacrifice
was the way to go because it would make
the anganga so much more powerful and
all their spells a lot more powerful
they just went to [__] town it seems
like now a lot of the things I read a
lot of the essays I read a lot of the
documentaries and stuff like that say
that many of the cult's victims were
like Rivals like their drug Rivals and
stuff like that which is true as far as
it goes but I think that's a little
dismissive because is one they're not
entirely sure how many people they
killed and there are stories that they
probably just killed random ass people
that they kidnapped off the street
because they're like oh the anganga
needs a heart or needs something like
that and they would just snatch somebody
off the street they think also that they
sacrificed well at least one kid that
they know of but maybe more than that
you know what I mean if if the anganga
needed youth then they would go snatch a
kid off because they absolutely had no
compunctions about doing that they
really did they seemed as it went on
they kind of got he was trying to get
his followers like desensitized yeah to
killing people to doing this stuff and
he would make because it does seem from
what I heard that at first like some of
his followers were like oh man this is
[__] up you know what I mean and like
we're throwing up and stuff but he would
just he would make them do [__] it's
like he would make them do [__] like to
people's dead bodies like even after
they were dead like we'll cut it up and
do this and that he was trying to
desensitize them so he did that as well
so yeah so like I said he took he takes
this brain and puts it in the anganga
and they had all of these other victims
yes many of them were rival but a lot of
it was just kind of small time [__] you
know what I mean it's just kind of like
hey here was these two guys who said
that these other drug people could put
you know could move their [__] through
this field and constanso didn't like
that so he's like let's go kill those
dudes you know what I mean so it wasn't
like a it wasn't like oh everybody they
killed was also bad people I don't think
it was like that they were just targets
of opportunity they were just targets of
opportunity and like I said I'm pretty
sure that some of them were just like
snatched off the street just random ass
people because they needed somebody so
there was that um what they would
normally do uh so they would they had a
um like a shack like on the ranch and
that's usually where they would take the
people and they would torture them for a
long time um usually also ad Doo would
rape
them the interesting thing about this
and I saw a couple documentaries point
this out they said he was real uh Keen
to make his followers uh you know
torture the people like cut off their
fingers and their penises and stuff um
but when he raped them he would make
everybody
leave maybe he had performance anxiety
May yeah it's like but it's like he'll
he'll cut people's brains out but it's
like he can't like have people watching
him like sodomize the people which I
thought was very too much pressure too
much performance guess it's not that
pressure yeah but yeah that was one of
the ways he would like torture maybe he
wasn't very impressive yeah maybe he
didn't want anybody to yeah
his San said Jenny did a deep dive on
this one I can tell yeah I mean this is
some crazy [__] she's good at that man
she'll investigate she'll [__] well
especially if it's true crime stuff it's
just kind of like I I just I just get
all down a rabbit hole you know what I
mean and for like two days I'll just be
like reading about this should be pull
it up I was reading about this horrible
[__] she a her in that brain is a
[__] Encyclopedia of this kind of
[__] yeah she's got a good memory too
which I'm not sure if that's like a good
thing but you know I don't understand
that's just the way my brain works I
can't help it it's just that's just what
my brain is interested in I'm like you
know there's not much I can do about
that well she's a horror writer and she
does a bunch of other [__] yeah I just
love that kind of [__] it's just like I
don't you know I don't love it because
obviously horrible things happen to
innocent people but I just I have like a
how she ended up with a crazy [__]
like me I think probably
yeah well but the thing about it is that
I'm not so bad
you like in comparison yeah you are not
crazy at all yeah right yeah yeah this
dude is [__] crazy I'm bad but I'm
not so bad that you can't [__] me see
that's and you're not really that bad
like I said compared to the
[__] I read about every day
you're not you don't even you're not
even on the scale you're not even you're
not even on the SP I have some honor if
I [__] you up there's a reason and I
think that's true of most people yeah
yeah most people would agree with me
[__] you up if I [__] you up they if
they knew the details like yeah I'd [__]
that dude up too so that's what I'm
saying like most of the time when you
say it's like yeah I'd [__] that dud I'm
like yeah I probably would too yeah you
know yeah and justice for me said anyone
bring Viagra to the ritual yeah it's
like why didn't you do that I don't know
like apparently a good drug it's one of
the best Tom loves that [__] I love VI
love I love testosterone I love
steroids I love hormones yeah you do
yeah I love Tren but Jen won't let me do
it anymore oh now oh you're putting that
on me now that I won't let you do no
it's correct
though I told you I I like I would I
would stop you from doing anything but
you have to understand the actions have
consequences you can do it if you want
but I'm going to I'm going to move out
I'll end up I'll end up in prison yeah
you know what I mean I when I was on
Trend I became the the goblin yeah you
did yeah you did yeah the Green
[Laughter]
Goblin yeah Zan also said this case is
almost too crazy to believe yeah this is
out there I mean this is out there like
I said this was during the satanic Panic
this is kind of what they were saying
all these Cults were doing in the United
States which they weren't but these
people were doing it these people were
doing it and they have like the but you
know as far as I know this is like the
worst one here's the difference
the reality of the [__] satanic Panic
was in Mexico and it was scumbags
running this little cult little two bit
Cults running around killing people and
trying to make money off drug cartels
the North American
fantasy of a satanic cult was a rich
powerful elevated [__] organization
on par with the [__] Catholic Church
that was breeding babies for SA
sacrifice and they were everywhere they
were in all the nodes of control they
were in the cops they were in the
[__] yeah it was this huge schools
they were [__] in the government it
was a [__] which that's a little
grandiose paranoia yeah and that they
were they controlled rock and roll music
and all the [__] record companies and
[__] yeah they made them put all these
like subliminal messages in there get
your children convered was masking and
it was a [__] awesome fantasy and if
you liked heavy metal you played into it
and it became black metal and that's
[__] hilarious man yeah yeah it was
you know but that's [__] hilarious so
like maybe it's like oh yeah we're
totally doing that I blame haraldo
Rivera I blame him for a lot of things
he he had a lot to do with that and I
blame Sally Jesse Raphael yeah they all
the all the daytime talk Phil donu well
you can blame them on the one hand but
you also kind of have to blame the
people that were watching that [__] too
and believing it employed people in in
in unemployed cuz I watched it too but I
knew it was all [__] it was mostly
unemployed women and I just thought it
was very funny who stayed at home but it
has real consequences that's why it's
shitty and watch that [__] all [__]
morning long and that's all that's being
like pounded into your brain like day
after day that all of this stuff is
going on even though it's not like all
that [__] was [__] fake that was in a
time when [__] television Ruled The
Roost it was the internet of the day boy
and I can't even go back and watch old
television programs that's how low
quality the information was it I didn't
realize it but television made you
stupider it made you dumb as [__] why
should that yeah yeah Z said Heraldo
Rivera gave away American troop
positions live on air during the second
Iraq war yeah I remember that guy is a
tool yeah he's a giant tool and like I
said all of that kind of I you can't
blame
them directly because people are
watching it people weren't watching it
they wouldn't do it you know what I mean
so it's kind of like a double-edged
sword it's like if you don't like it
don't watch it and if nobody watched it
then they wouldn't make it you know that
too but yeah I can totally blame like
haralo Rivera is a [__] tool he's
still he's still a [__] tool yeah
he's is he still alive yeah that whole
generation of [__] television they're
all kind they're all [__] tools to be
honest yeah they were all they were all
tools yeah yeah so the only one that was
kind of not a tool was Ricky Lake
because she was obvious that she was
just about fun that she didn't take any
of that [__] seriously Ricky yeah yeah I
remember that like I didn't even mind
like the ones that were just about like
silly topics yeah but you know the ones
that were kind of like you know about
satanists or all this other kind of
stuff like I said that
is the important question about Ricky
lake is that was she cuter when she was
skinny or when she got
fat because some people preferred fat
Ricky I think she was kind of cute
either way well she was hairspray yeah
the John Waters movie and I thought she
was quite cute in that as Tracy turnblad
yeah and the whole point of that
character was that she was you know
heavy yeah but I thought I thought she
was cute as [__] that she first started
the the the show though she wasn't that
heavy she gained weight later on the
Ricky Lake Show at least she lost weight
first yeah she kind of went up and down
and then she [__] gained kind of went
up and down and there was like there was
like a [__] group of guys that during
the during those days would be like well
what was better skinny Ricky lake or fat
Ricky Lake Ricky Lake she wasn't really
fat she was just chubby chubby Ricky
Lake was cute yeah I thought though yeah
yeah yeah when she got thin she still
looked good but she kind of looked like
like generic generic yeah like when she
was heavier she kind of had her own
thing going on and I was kind of like
yeah I like that game it's like I like
that like I said I especially liked her
in Hairspray she looked like she could
give head she was she was adorable in it
she looked like she could give head when
she was fat I was like yeah she'
probably be good at give it aead that's
just that that's not me saying that that
my friends were saying that too really
yeah what what are Steve were like
there's just something she could
probably give had what what are the what
are the parameters of that something
about the mouth and the face oh okay
yeah back but she probably would have
had the same thing if she was thin
though no there's something different
about it fat girls [__] give good
head they tend to interesting yeah oral
fixation
maybe I had heard that before but I'm
not I mean I'm not sure if that's true
across the board but like I said well
you know I got a big body count tell you
well that's what I mean you you're a
statistical outlier so maybe you can uh
yeah no I I I did kind of note
that noted yeah I kind of noted that in
his little book who gives the best
[__] Tom's book of best BL yeah yeah
oh was like in those days I've noticed
that girls over X pounds yeah yeah give
per whatever percentage more aggressive
they were also more aggressive they'd
[__] track your ass down to [__]
blow you track your ass down I told you
that story [__] yeah Carrie's sister
yeah yeah well you know they don't got
nothing to lose man they're just kind of
like and and they're used and I guess
they're kind of getting used to like
passed over so like I'm just going to go
after what I want something they got to
shine at something then they do shine
they do shine at that yeah I mean
they're not all like that obviously
because I knew a lot of w like that but
but yeah I have I know what you're
talking about though I know what you're
talking about they try
harder yeah well I mean you kind of have
to have something to offer yeah right
because when you're heavier you don't
you know a lot of dudes won't look at
you so you have to kind of yeah although
you know come at it a different talked
about it
before there are some women that
actually can really genetically just
carry weight they look real good you
know what I mean the brothers know what
I'm talking about they got some women
that the thing is though is that you can
only that for a certain amount of time
once they start get hitting in their 30s
and 40s a lot of times the skin just
can't hold up up to that amount of
[__] gravity but they got Instagram
models that are at least
[__] 60 70 pounds overweight but they
[__] curvy as hell they look good
yeah it's all where it is it's where it
is where it's distributed if it's real
[__] hourglass then yeah you can get
away with
it Denny says uh BBW Ricky Lake was
hotter I think she was and also seral
Mom Ricky was hot oh we need to man we
need to review Serial Mom yeah that's
John Waters movie
Ricky L was in that kathle Turner was in
that oh it's so good I love that movie
we need to do more John Waters movies
now that I'm thinking about it I think
we oh they're they're going off and on
about amen Tom who said this [__] I just
saw who said Injustice for me who said
that Injustice for me said amen Tom
Crome off a trailer hitch yeah exactly
exactly I have heard that yeah yeah yeah
I have heard that yeah yeah they try
hard yeah I mean you know I was heavier
in high school but I I don't know if
that was true of me probably not
probably not I never had anybody say
that about me that I know of so so I
don't really know um yeah so let's see
where were we okay so we get we get off
on these [__] tangents why does that
always happen um so yeah okay so their
whole thing was that when they were
doing this to the people they tried to
do as much as possible when the people
were still alive like they would cut off
fingers cut off toes cut off genitals
like [__] with it usually men that they
targeted I don't know if they killed a
lot of women I think all the bodies that
they found were
men um you know so they you know cut off
their ears that was another big thing
and they would also I think a couple
times they even tried to skin them alive
uh so there was that too because they
believed that the more the victim
suffered and the more that they screamed
than the more
powerful um their body parts would be
when you put them in the in ganga you
know what I mean so some [__]
that just like sat there and was all
stoic and [__] like that that [__]
wasn't going to work you had to have
somebody that was like freaking out and
like you know that was in a lot of pain
they thought that would make that like a
lot more powerful so that's why they
were doing a lot of this stuff to people
so apparently what they would do is that
they would take the body parts and then
put them in the cauldron and then kind
of boil them and then the followers
would like drink out of that which I
know it's gross as [__] that like makes
me want to gag um and they thought that
by drinking out of the anganga that it
made them
bulletproof and also invisible to law
enforcement spoiler alert it did not but
they thought that it
did also and this is fun this will come
up later when we're talking about the
murder of Mark killroy um another thing
that they did was that they would wear
necklaces made out of their victim's
backbones and there was a there was a
very special particular way that they
would get them out and it's it's pretty
fun not really but I'm just
saying so
yeah now they also had like all the cult
members that were that had killed
somebody they got their little uh
branding kind of marks they would put
like little marks they would heat up a
knife and they would put kind of
everybody had like a different Mark you
had like a different little shape or a
different figure or whatever and they
would put that like all over you like
little hatch marks or whatever now I
will say that this habit that they had
of occasionally just like snatching some
[__] people off the street if they
needed a sacrifice at least one time
kind of worked against them cuz what
happened this one particular time was
that they were like okay well we need
somebody to sacrifice like toot sweet so
you guys need to just go out and just
just grab the first person you see it
doesn't matter who it is so they went
out onto the ranch because it was like a
big you know property or whatever and
they just grabbed the first person they
saw which happened to be a 14-year-old
boy now they put a hood over his head
and they brought him back to the um you
know the the shack where they would do
the [__] now
Hernandez he takes a machete and lops
the kid's head off damn he takes the
hood off it's his cousin
oh that worked on the farm damn and then
like the mom also lived there and she's
like where's my where did my kid go you
know what I mean and they're just like
uh we don't know I mean apparently he
was real broken up about it but it's
like well that's shouldn't have got
involved
that what goes around comes around that
should be a red flag right there it's
like one before you cut someone's head
off at least check who it is I mean you
know that's really messed up it's like I
was like I heard that and I was just
like oh my God that is [__] horrible
that's [__] horrible it's a
14-year-old kid yeah he just happened to
be the first person he he like worked on
the farm he like took care of the
animals or something and they just saw
him it's like hey there's one and they
you know the guys who grabbed him didn't
know who he was so they just brought him
to the thing and he had a hood over his
head and the guy was like all right I'll
just do this real quick to show that I'm
a member of the cult he's like a [__]
and he was do a lot of damage uh yeah
that's the lesson there yeah well
there's a lot of lessons there but that
is one of the main lessons yes um idiots
do a lot of damage now at this stage
this is spring of 1989
now adalo says to his cult people I want
you to bring me a gringo you know a
white man for the next sacrifice because
this is going to bring us more power for
us now this request reportedly this is
what I've
heard um came after another sacrifice
that he had done like
recently and the dude that he
sacrificed absolutely did not scream the
entire he didn't make a [__] peep the
whole time like even though he's being
tortured and [__] like that and this
upset adalo a lot because he's just kind
of because I think he were in the
bathroom but he believed that the more
they screamed the more they suffered the
more powerful the magic would be he must
have overheard him say that so if he
just like sits there and doesn't like
won't give him the satisfaction and this
a guy like I said apparently not give
him you know didn't make a peep took it
like a [__] like a [__] Soldier
yeah right and he just didn't make a
noise so cuz well that well that one was
no good I can't I can't use that dude's
Parts in the anganga um years back I saw
a video CU I get set videos every now
and then [__] murder Hornet sent me
some of them some I couldn't saw one
where the cartel was cutting off this
woman's head she was alive they would
cut it off with a [__] pocket knife
basically small 3-in knife for being a
rat and she leaned into it she didn't
make a [__] sound she just looked at
that dude in in the
[__] I mean she probably knew it was
dud [__] cut her head off looking at
her yeah that was [__] and she didn't
make a sound well apparently this guy
[__] that's take some balls right there
yeah and a a woman can they have a
higher pain threshold than generally
they do yeah uh but [__] still he
hacked her [__] head off I feel like
getting your head cut off is a whole
other level it wasn't chopped it was cut
off and he was oh it was [__]
bad the spite that she had was more
powerful she leaned into it and looked
at him and [__] she's like [__] buddy
yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's my hero right there so I
guess that's how you do
it cuz like I said they're you know
they're going to kill you anyway yeah so
you might as well not give them the
satisfaction satisfaction although I
kind of feel like most people are going
to scream whether they want to or not
because uh shit's she was a civilian she
was in the cartel too right so she knew
yeah
yeah um yeah Zan said wow I had never
heard that story about yeah so that's
what I heard anyway that he had
sacrificed a dude but the dude didn't
make any sound like he didn't scream and
he's like well it doesn't work that's
you know that that was a wasted one um
so he's like so I kind of want somebody
that he called
soft and he particularly wanted here's
another weird thing he also wanted the
brain a new brain for his
inanga um and he wanted a smarter brain
so he specifically I've heard that he
specifically asked for a med student
which is what this guy uh was um but he
wanted somebody that was when American
college student because he thought that
would be like a smarter like a superior
brain that he could put in his cauldron
you know what I mean the smart ass gr
goes yeah also um he thought that well
everybody we've sacrificed thus far has
been Mexican and that's worked out for
us for us on this side of the Border
like we haven't been caught or you know
nothing bad has happened but it's like
if we sacrifice an American then that
protection will be extended like to that
side of the border so he seemed to
believe that or that's what he told his
followers anyway so he was basically
like hey go get me a white
dude um so there was
that so the victim that they ended up
getting uh and this was quite a famous
case uh this was on America's Most
Wanted and everything like back when it
happened back in
1989 was Mark Kilroy now he was
originally from uh Santa Fe Texas not
Santa Fe New Mexico and he was kind of
like the the platonic ideal of like the
All-American guy you know what I mean
he's quite tall you know pretty
goodlooking had like blonde hair um he
was was really good at school like he
was one of the top students um he was a
really good athlete you know he played
all these different sport baseball
basketball golf BL blah he was a boy
scout uh he was an honor student he was
on the student council all this other
kind of [__] so we graduated from high
school in
1986 and then he went to Southwest Texas
State University that's in San Marcos
Texas and then he transferred to um is
it Tarlton or Tarlton I'm not really
sure I'm not from Texas um in
Stevensville and he went there on a
basketball scholarship so that's how
good uh an athlete he was he was in a
fraternity and everything like that um
but then he decided he was going to go
to med school so he went to the
University of Texas at Austin and went
into
Premed so classes L out for spring break
uh on March 10th
1989 so Mark and three of his friends
whose names were Bradley Moore Bill
huddon and Brent
Martin they're going to go down to
Mexico for spring break as thousands and
thousands of college students did then
and likely still
do so at first they went to South Padre
Island in Texas and they were going to
you know just do spring break [__] they
were going to like hang out on the beach
try to pick up girls drink a lot and
blah blah um and at night they were
going to go over to Matamoros in Mexico
which is literally you walking distance
you just walk across the bridge and
you're in Mexico you know what I mean uh
and obviously the drinking age in Mexico
is much lower than it is in the United
States so that's why a lot of college
kids would walk over there you know what
I mean so they could go and drink and
everything was fine and there was like
tons of tourists and all that other kind
of stuff so um I put down this little
detail because I thought you would
appreciate this time one of the things
that they did while they were on their
spring break their hotel would have
every day
a beauty contest but it was very
specifically a Miss tan line contest I
love tan line I know that's why I
thought that was funny and I thought I
would write that I'm like wouldn't they
run out of women with I guess not I got
every single day they're having that I
got the tan line fetish back in the 70s
when I was a little kid living in
California [__] it just I just
thought t girls would [__] take a lot
of sun well apparently you're not the
only one cuz they had a whole beauty
contest back in the late
1980s judging who had the
[__] Tan Lines a lot which is that's
very funny they were even showing tan
lines like in [__] Penthouse and
Hustler back in those days I was like
[__] show advertising some chicks tan
it's kind of like you see the lines of
underwear lingerie on the woman and
she's not wearing anything so she's got
clothes on and clothes off at the same
time yeah Tom digs that yeah dig well
that's why I wrote that whole thing down
because one I thought it was kind of
funny cuz I was like wow what a specific
beauty contest but I was like oh Tom
loves tan lines so I'm going to write
that down cuz I have have to remember to
mention that that's out of style you
don't see it anymore not really
yeah um but yeah oh [__] I think I
forgot to mention this is I should have
mentioned this at the beginning but we
got like kind of off on a thing we have
a new Patron oh we do okay yeah I meant
to mention at the very beginning but I
only just remember now that's good Kelly
G Kelly G so hi Kelly G she also sent me
like a really nice message she sent me a
couple messages before and she was just
like I swear I'm not your lesbian
stalker okay but she's a lesbian stalker
cuz well no cuz she she's like I got my
husband into your show and it's just
like he'll watch the stuff and
everything but um she thinks I'm
hilarious which is I am kind of no she
is yeah but you know probably not as
hilarious as you are but I'm no
everybody's hilarious but I'm also
pretty shake that drink up what shake it
oh yeah oh my [__] s look well what am I
supposed to do about this is what I did
out in the back I grow passion fruit I
make onion fruit passion fruit I make my
own passion fruit juice as they fall off
a [__] tree off the vine all right I
got to pee though hold on let me I got
to pee so what did she say in in the
comments well she didn't say anything
that's it I just no she sent me an email
uhhuh but it's just I just remember that
I was supposed to mention that she's a
new Pat
okay I'm just kind of mixing up her
drink J will be back in a second but no
uh I'll go ahead and plug
patrons of course um we don't the show
is mostly
demonetized we do get a ad revenue on
some stuff but usually because of the
content and what we're talking about we
get
demonetized so the show basically
survives off now
patrons and we do that [__] off patreon
we do get some super chats and every now
and then we'll get a super
thanks um if you are listening to the
show
recorded and you send a super thanks we
almost always respond to that super
super thanks [__] um in a text so I
just want to thank y'all who have
already given us a super super thanks
and encouraging other people to give
super thanks and super chats because
that's how we keep the show
going uh let me see what we have going
here see if I have anybody Who's
Talking Now murder Hornet says that
mango badger was the genital mutilator
no I don't know about that genital
mutilator yeah what did I miss and then
Zan saying said the bees nest murder
Hornet probably hung out with this guy
yeah yeah probably murder Hornet yeah oh
yeah maybe yeah Jenny's the brains of
the operation Tom is the comic Rel well
really when we first started the
show we kind of had a uh kind of an
Abbot and Costello kind of [__] thing
where she was the straight man and I was
the comic relief that was that was
usually how it went some of the [__]
younger audience didn't really uh
respond to that too well like why do he
keep interrupting it's a
show we're talk we're trying to kill
time you're at work or you're driving I
do the same thing okay I like to listen
to Wang I like there's a lot of shows I
like like toist listen to when I'm
driving especially I drove from here to
Mississippi listening to Wang the whole
time man he killed [__] 10 hours a
drive and it was like that I mean I used
to listen to like Simon Whistler driving
back and forth like on my long commute
toing from work and there are some
YouTube shows that I [__] will put on
if I want to go to sleep and it's no
disrespect to that show I love that show
and it keeps you relaxed kind of
comforting yeah and I [__] just kind
of drift off and then I'll go back and
listen to him over and over again you
know so oh thank you very much who thank
you very much side quest hero just
showed up and gave us a Super Chat yeah
I think that's a female in side quest
humor I think it's a female I mean the
picture looks like but it's very
much yeah Z said I never heard the story
about the guy chopping his own cousin's
head off that's [__] up now well some
of the sources I saw said it was his
nephew but one of the more definitive
ones said it was his cousin so it was
either his nephew or his cousin I mean
it was still a relative and they were 14
yeah can you [__] imagine that's a
little baby yeah can you [__] imagine
it's like well one like I said lesson
there don't just be like snatching
random people up hey let's just snatch a
random person and then cut their head
off yeah let's let's not do that let's
just don't do that um and and then you
won't have this kind of thing happen to
he was like oh no it's actually my you
know it's actually my relative it's just
you know lesson learned lesson
learned so yeah um so Mark uh you know
the was going to the m tanline contest I
don't know why that was so funny to me
I'm like cuz like I said it's you know
it's spring break all the hotels are
going to be filled with college students
so obviously they're going to have [__]
like I don't know cream corn wrestling
or something that maybe that's more a
biker thing but um but you know they're
going to have Beauty contests they're
going to have hot chicks and bikinis and
blah blah um thank you very much is that
wallcat okay yeah I sorry I can't see
that good uh thank you very much enjoy
your channel appreciate the hard work it
must take a lot of time it does yeah but
um thank you very much thank you very
much for the super chats very very nice
of you um so yeah so I just thought it
was very
funny that they had a very specific
beauty contest that was all about tan
lines and like I said that made me laugh
because Tom's really into Tan Lines
because he's always trying to get me to
lay out in the sun and do it I'm just
like I'm not I'm a goth I'm not laying
on the sun [__] that so you know what I
mean if you really want me to it's like
just you can draw them on there if you
want but it's like I like my pness I'm
I'm not into the tan thing but yeah so
you know he did try to get me to do that
for a while but I'm not going to do that
like I said you can draw it on me with
paint if you want but I'm not doing it
from real life oh is that another Super
Chat yes it is thank you very much
fromat
whcat thank you very much enjoy your
channel appreciate the hard work oh
appreciate appreciate it thank you very
much I mean I do enjoy doing these shows
though but we like the show we like
hanging out with y'all but we do like to
make money
also I like money yeah I like money you
like money I can't believe that you like
money I know man I can't believe
that yeah that's like the second
idiocracy thing we've made today did I
because I made a brondo like joke
earlier when we were in Dollar General
idiocracy is a masterpiece if haven't
seen yeah I made a brondo joke earlier
yeah [__] cuz you said something some
Dr some weird drink we saw in Dollar
General I said it's what it's what
plants cve yeah it's what PLS grave just
out Zada me and zanada [__] talk off
the show a lot send messages he sends a
lot of movies we review them I'm kind of
like his mentor on what [__] high
quality movie to watch next another one
I I got to put you on bro idiocracy if
you haven't seen it it's [__] I kind
of feel like everybody's seen that it's
hard find that movie maybe not cuz they
kind of try to suppress it oh I don't
know about that I think it's it's pretty
easy to get I heard I heard that the
companies like fud Ruckers and all the
people that funded it did not like that
movie because they changed the name to
butt [__] and [__] like that it was
like a very look if you're if you're
naming your restaurant fud Ruckers you
can't be mad that's what's G to happen
because that's what everybody's thinking
of and you wanted everybody to think
that or you wouldn't have named it fut
Ruckers in the first place so let's not
get all yeah the people that did all
about it the people that did the product
placement were not happy it didn't it
didn't run along in theaters but it's
it's well it it became like a cult it
got a big cult fall like later on yeah
Eric Al Lyn said I oh my God I got a
comment on this I remember the stickers
they sold at the tanning salon to get a
tan line sticker they were like Playboy
Bunny stickers and cherries yeah you
know what's funny when I was a little
kid I had a doll that was like a Barbie
doll um I can't remember what her name
was though I'll remember it in a second
but she not only had a turnable scalp
like she had blonde hair on one side and
black hair on the other side so you
could like turn it around and change her
hair color but you also she had all
these stickers and you could put on her
body and then lay her out in the sun and
then she would get a tan yeah and then
she would get what the [__] was the name
of that thing look I want to tell you
girls something [__] even to this day I
know how men operate if you had a tan
and you used a sticker and you had a
Playboy bunny or some [__] tacky
[__] thing like that on your ass
dudes would [__] love it the tackier
that [__] tack [__] [__] the the
hotter they would think you were yeah
yeah Tom also loves tacky [__] [__]
he'll be like scrolling through Teemu or
something like that like looking cuz he
buys me clothes all the time yeah and
he'll go through there and be like look
at this I'm just like [__] I would
never wear that tack as [__] I'm like
that's terrible I just want to [__] you
in it though I don't want you walking
around in it that much like I'm not
going outside in underwear that sets
Juicy Fruit over the booty and [__] yeah
it looks like the gum wrapper like a gum
wrapper yeah like if you want to spend
your money on that fine but it's just
like I'm not wearing that I'm not
wearing that guys like tacky I know I
know they do there's a there's a element
of [__] eroticism to it just like
yeah okay y' y'all just all tacky
[__] you can't help him yeah
well it's tacky with a sense of humor
yeah okay that's that's fair enough yeah
as long as you don't make me wear it
outside the house or don't take a
picture of me and send it to everybody
you know oh I'd love to do that like
yeah I know you would you of heard to
[__] murder Hornet [__] anybody
[__] booty I have no idea I have no
idea you took most of the photos you
well I know that yeah I know I took them
but it's like I didn't send them to
anybody but it's like I have no idea to
whom he has sent them to yeah I know
some of the people he sent them to but
he could be sending them to anybody like
random ass people and I don't know
usually trading usually trading for
stuff yeah so we're we're getting
something out of it it's part of our
[__] porn Enterprise anyway that's
true yeah as long as you don't send like
terrible shitty pictures cuz some cuz
sometimes you like pictures of me that I
don't really like and I would rather
other people like certain kind of
pictures that women don't tend to like
but [__] know a lot of pictures you
took that were [__] like elegant and
you look great in them [__] I change
my I got that [__] on my [__] on my
[__] tablets he does yeah I'm at
Starbucks and [__] scrolling all my
[__] background screens are [__]
Jenny with [__] boobs and [__]
[__] they she looks great in them
though I mean yeah that's that's pretty
flattering right oh yeah at least he's
not like putting some other random check
up there they're all of me they're all
of me yeah but here here's one of them
she got clothes yeah I got clothes on
that one yes [__] like that yeah the
other some she doesn't have clothes the
other one I don't have clothes I know I
know the other one that you're I
change that's that's a great that's a
cute Jenny picture I got my blue
contacts in yeah that's a cute Jenny
picture I got blue contacts I got green
contacts I got red
contacts yeah side side quest hero said
dude Dollar General is dope they sell
ripet yeah yeah when I was in the Army
ripet was like the energy drink we got
in the chow hall and the only place they
have them now is to General we have one
like literally right right there right
there like you can walk to I'll go down
there and get a gallon of milk or buy
cheese or it's so convenient get a
[__] 2 lit yeah it's convenient a lot
of candy get Little Debbie C we just
went there today yeah we go there a lot
buy little [__] tricks cuz it's right
there you get Temptations for the cats
yeah we get we get all the cat treats
there I just I went there today cuz I
had to get coffee creamer I can't not
have coffee creamer I ran out I love
Dollar General yeah it's only why that
[__] food deserts out in the country
yeah out here they are everywhere yeah
you know grocery stores are kind of like
few and far but we do have a Publix like
only a mile or so up the road but you
know what I mean we'll go there if we
want like better stuff but Subs yeah
[__] badass ice cream I bought some
of that cheap ass Dollar Store [__]
ice cream in the Big Tub the cookies and
cream they can't even call it ice cream
they call it frozen
dessert you get a big gallon of that
[__] for like [__] six bucks it's
[__] good pretty good yeah it's good
don't be afraid of
it it won't hurt it's not ice cream cuz
there's no cream in it they use milk and
then to fortify the fat in there they've
used [__] vegetable oils yeah okay so
they legally can't call it cream it
still tastes okay though but it's still
good the only difference is is that it's
per cup there's more calories in it that
that that's but if you're already eating
ice cream not a big concern you know all
right so where was I we got distracted
with the Miss tanine competition as I
knew would happen but I I had to mention
it I love you like I said she had tanin
one time she looked [__] so great I
was like he's like I said he's trying to
get me to lay I'm like I'm not laying on
the trying to get her to sit on my face
all the
time I'll do that anyway I don't need
tan line do
that you know what I mean so yeah Miss
tan line
so this see this is what happens this is
what happen yeah but I was just thinking
I was listening to some last podcast on
the left earlier I'm like they kind of
do that too though like they talk about
all this true crime and stuff like that
but then they go off on these big long
tents it's like super fun they've been
around like forever it's a natural thing
to do I think maybe people thought we
were copying them but I didn't even
actually start listening to them until
when you do a show like this that
naturally is going to happen yeah I mean
and especially you're drinking yeah
especially if you're drink especially if
you're live streaming and you have like
other people interact
yeah
haveing and I never know what he going
to say because he usually all the
details of these do so yeah so I don't
know how he's going to react to like
this [__] that I say yeah so that's kind
of what makes it fun so at this okay so
Mark killroy at this stage had only just
turned 21 so they're all going him and
his three friends they're all going on
this big adventure like down for spring
break or everything like that they're
just like you know hanging on the beach
drinking flirting with ladies whatever
so March 13
the night of March 13th
1989 so this was kind of when spring
break started like for real like they
had like 15,000 people like kind of
flood into the area in monores because
it's a big that's a like I said it's
right over the Border like you can
literally walk to it from Brownsville
Texas like just right across a bridge so
people are just kind of flooding into
the town there's all kind of bars it's a
whole real touristy area um you know and
I don't know what it's like now but
that's what it was like back then so
Mark and his so it was super were
crowded like all the bars were crowded
the streets were crowded everything so
Mark and his buddies um they're bar
hopping all night going from one to the
other now around 2: in the morning one
of the friends says you know let's go
back to South Padre Island in Texas
where they were before so they come out
of one Pub the London pub is what it's
called they came out of there and they
see Mark kind of leaning against a car
and he's talking to one of the women
that was in the M tan line competition
cuz he was was like trying to pick her
up or
whatever and so at this point like I
said the streets were really crowded
people are coming out of the bars cuz
they're closing and stuff like that so
it's really packed and they're having a
hard time the four of them are having a
hard time like staying together you know
what I mean like staying in a
group so at one point two of the friends
kind of separated from the group and
they went over to this kind of like
restaurant store kind of situation
called Garcia is um they're just real
close to the border now Mark um is kind
of like stops on these steps of this
house on the street to say goodbye to
the miss tanline lady and then he was
waiting for the other friend to come
toward him now the other friend comes
toward him but then he's like man I got
to pee so he goes into an alley to pee
and Mark said okay well I'll wait out
here for you but by the time that that
friend who was Huddleston came out and
found the other two guys who were in
front of Garcia's Mark was
gone now the three friends started
looking for him and they looked for him
like pretty much all
night um and then they were like well
maybe he just went back to Brownsville
cuz that's where their cars were they
had parked them like over in Texas and
had walked over the bridge so it's like
well maybe he just you know maybe he
just went back so let's go over there
and check so they crossed the border
back into Brownsville uh to see if he
was by the car but he wasn't there so
they hung around for a little bit and
then they're like okay we're going to go
back to South Padre Island where they
had kind of started out from and then
it's like maybe he picked somebody up
and left the hotel with somebody like
maybe he met a girl or something so
they're like okay we're not going to
worry about it too much so they you know
they were kind of drunk and hung over or
whatever and so they fell asleep now
when they woke up at the hotel the next
morning uh Mark was obviously uh still
not there and they could not contact him
this was 1989 so there were no cell
phones or anything like that
obviously so at that point um they
called the cops and reported him
missing now the investigation at first
no one was super alarmed because you
know they just kind of started it out as
like a regular missing person's
investigation because it's like this
this is a big spring break touristy area
there's a lot of very young people uh
drinking a great deal and uh a lot of
times most of the time I would Hazard to
say uh the people would turn up a day or
two later so hung over that they didn't
even know what had [__] happened like
they had no memory of what had happened
like most of them turned up fine is is
what I'm getting
at um and as a matter of fact Mark was
actually one of 60 people who had
disappeared from M moros only in the
first 3 months of 1989 so you can see
why they weren't super alarmed at first
they said most of these people are just
drunk and they're wandering off and they
just didn't remember what happened and
they just kind of came to someplace else
and were like how the [__] did I get
here and like eventually made their way
home and everything was fine so they
didn't really think anything about it
but because Mark
killroy was kind of slightly connected
like he had an uncle that worked in the
US Custom Service in
La um and when his uncle found out about
it like he raised a big stink he's like
we really need to like figure out where
this kid went cuz he wouldn't just like
wander off like that so they did put a
task for for together in Brownsville
Texas to look for him and there were
also kind of threats of look you know
you guys like Matamoros is very known
for like American tourism and stuff and
it's like if this gets around that like
people are being snatched off the street
or whatever then you know your tourism
trade might go down and blahy
blah so they also tried to it seemed
like um the local police were trying to
maybe say oh well he must have gone back
to Brownsville and disappeared there
like they were trying to like make it
not their problem you know what I mean
but his friends are like no he
absolutely disappeared on this side of
the
border now it seems that from the early
day like when Mark didn't turn
up they thought
maybe that you know he had been
essentially probably kidnapped and
murdered and that maybe his
disappearance was drug related or was
maybe um like a robbery gone wrong type
of thing
but they didn't really have any leads to
go
on now when they were trying
to you know kind of find some Clues and
stuff they did actually bring in a hypn
hypnotist to hypnotize the three friends
to see if they could remember anything
that would help them now one of the
friends more he said under hypnosis that
he remembered that he had seen a
Hispanic man like a young guy who was
wearing a blue plaid shirt and had a
scar on his face and that he had talked
to Mark before Mark's disappearance he
said that the man walked up to Mark and
said hey don't I know you from somewhere
but he said he didn't know if like Mark
had answered
him but nobody's entirely sure if that's
exactly what happened or if that was
just suggested through
hypnosis because the friends they didn't
really know where or when exactly he had
disappeared like I said cuz the two
other guys had gone off to this other a
restaurant and we're hanging out over
there and this other friend had like
gone in an alley to pee or something
like that he'd been talking to some
chick and it's just kind of like I came
back out of the alley and he was gone
you know what I mean so they didn't
really know like which direction he'd
gone so they were like well maybe you
know the authorities are like well maybe
he was kidnapped you know like I said
maybe he got robbed and they killed him
and they just dumped him somewhere or
maybe he was kidnapped for ransom
although they said probably not because
you know nobody came forward and like
ask for any money or anything like that
so they started doing like a search they
had helicopters and all this other kind
of stuff that were like you know
trolling the river and all this other
kind of stuff but they didn't find
anything so a little while later like
probably about 2 weeks after he
disappeared um they profiled the case on
America's Most Wanted which kind of make
made it like blow up like across the US
like everybody saw that [__] everybody
was talking about it um and you know a
lot of people like phoned in with leads
and stuff but none of them really went
anywhere now it so happened the big
break in the case how they found out not
only what happened to Mark killroy but
also exposed the entire matamoro cult
who had been operating kind of under the
radar up until this point this is what
happened so there were some Mexican
federales and they were watching like a
checkpoint like a drug checkpoint they
you know people were smuggling or
whatever and they were all at a
checkpoint and this car ran through the
checkpoint with the roadblock like
without stopping just Breeze right
through it like it like like it wasn't
no
thing and the the car was coming from
Texas and then like went into Mexico and
the cops were like huh that's something
so they actually had the presence of
mind to be like you know what we're not
going to chase that dude like we're not
going to turn the sirens on and alert
him or anything we're just going to
follow him and see where he goes because
what is this all about he just ran
through the roadblock like he's just
like whatever you know what I mean they
thought that was kind of weird so
they're like okay we're going to follow
him so they followed it in an unmarked
vehicle now this vehicle went out to the
Santa Elena Ranch which if you'll recall
is where the monor's cult that's where
they were killing people so he it went
out there so the cops followed him they
saw him go in there and then they were
like okay we're just going to pull off
we're going to see what happened so
they're just watching now the car is
there for about half an hour and then
the driver like leaves the ranch and
goes back to the
city and then they're like okay well
we're going to go and search the ranch
because evidently at I don't know about
now but evidently at this time in Mexico
you you know you didn't need a search
warrant you could just be like H we
suspect some shit's going on there we
just going to bust in so they did so
they went in the ranch and started
looking
around now while they were looking
around they found uh some traces of
marijuana and also found some uh cult
parapan candles and that kind of
[__] now eventually they found out that
the person who had been driving the
truck the vehicle that had gone through
the checkpoint was none other than
sarapen Hernandez Garcia who they called
little seraphine I believe is what
because he was like kind of a little
dude now he was again a member of the
big you know drug cartel uh Hernandez
family and that's where their operations
were now the cops when they found out
who he was they knew about the Hernandez
Family who like I said were not a huge
drug cartell family but they were kind
of midlevel he's like we're just going
to chill out and we're just going to
like see how this plays
out so they decided to like watch him
and also kind of like ask some other
informants about what was going on out
at that ranch you know what I mean so
they did that for a little while and
then a little while later like on the
9th of April they came back with a bunch
of cops and arrested him uh little
sarapen as well as his uncle ilio who
was the head of the Hernandez cartel
thing and a couple of other cult members
like three other cult members and the um
caretaker of the
ranch now it turned out that the person
who had driven through the roadblock
like I said was
saraphi and the reason that he had
driven through the roadblock they
discovered later was because he thought
that adalo constanzo's magic was so
powerful that the cops could not see
him that's why okay yeah that's why he
drove through the roadblock yeah they
can't see me wee and they're like Native
Americans thought that that they could
become invisible Army back in the day
yeah yeah but I mean from his thing from
his point of view I mean it seemed like
they did because they did follow him but
they didn't like come after him with
like guns blazing or like sirens blaring
or anything like that they just kind of
followed him at a distance because they
wanted to see what he was up to but he
thought that they couldn't see him um
and apparently when they eventually
arrested him he was super shocked that
they had actually been able to see him
which I thought was kind of funny cuz
like I said the um the thing that doc
that that Zan us at me it had footage
like police footage of him of uh little
seraphine at the ranch like telling them
where all the bodies were buried and
stuff and he just seemed like he seemed
very young I'm not really sure how young
but he seemed kind of like a kid you
know what I mean the weird thing about
it was that he also
seemed like he didn't think he was going
to get like he didn't think he was in
any trouble
like he wasn't cocky or anything like
that but he was just like acting like
everything was normal like he didn't
think he was going to get in any trouble
for any of this [__] which I thought was
kind of bizarre but yeah so he was just
so he was like really shocked when he
arrested him because he's like oh my God
I didn't think you guys could see me and
um but yeah so they arrested some of the
cult members along with him and um again
they all seemed pretty chill like I said
I think they all thought they were
protected by Magic and like nothing bad
was going to happen it seemed like so
they
questioned the caretaker at the ranch
and they later determined I don't think
he knew anything about that what was
going on there he was just kind of would
come and go like to watch the property
or whatever but I don't think he knew he
wasn't in the cult or anything now he
told the cops though that he's like yeah
um you know they bring all these people
here they're like there's all these
people here um from sarapin like the
Hernandez family they come here and it's
like sometimes they bring people here
and those people don't leave and then
when they showed him a picture of Mark
Kroy he's like yeah I saw him and then
he said he was over there they took him
over there to the
shack so then the cops go back and
question Lil
sarapen and he conf just casual as you
please um he's like yeah um there have
been a bunch of people killed out here
they're like the the documentary that
Zan sent me there was like an interview
with one of the Brownsville cops that
had investigated the case he said we
took the little dude out to the ranch
and they have footage of this um and
said because they were looking for Mark
killroy right they didn't know at this
point that there were a bunch of other
bodies out there and so they were like
okay well where's the body and he says
to them which one they he said like it
was nothing yeah right which one are you
talking which one damn he's like what do
you mean which one there's a [__] ton of
them he's like yeah there's a bunch of
them
damn it was yeah it was like that and
and the dude the cop that was on there
was just flabbergasted like you could
tell he's like just the Casual way that
he went like which
one and then he just like I said I don't
think the dude thought that he was going
to get any trouble I I think was was
what it was he thought he was
protected so he's like yeah there's all
kind of there's all kind of people
there's a dude over there and there's a
dude over there and there's a dude over
there and um he's like yeah it was um IL
padrino you know ad Doo castano that's
what they called him The Godfather and
he's like yeah he killed all kind of
people out here um you know it's
protection they're sacrificing people
like for protection for all the for all
the drug
cartels and um you know and then he
later told them it's like yeah and he
specifically asked us to find a gringo
to
sacrifice and that's where Mark is
buried over
there and then he told them now some
sources I read some said that he just
confessed willingly like the cop on the
documentary when they interviewed him he
said that he's like I never cuz he um
acknowledged that the Mexican police at
that time I don't know about nowadays
but at that time they didn't have any um
they didn't have any compunction about
torturing people to get um information
out of them what did they call it moral
pressure he said that's what they called
it moral pressure but it was
torture um but he said according to him
he said they didn't have to torture
little saraphi he just told him [__]
like whatever but other sources I read
said that he was tortured so I don't
know which thing is true regardless of
which thing is true sarapen said this is
what happened he said yeah it was me and
a few other members of the you know of
the cult and we went we had been told to
find a gringo so we went down to M moros
because we knew all the Spring Breakers
were going to be there so we were down
there on you know overnight of 13th 14th
March they said they saw Mark killroy um
some sources said that they had been
following him and you know cuz he's kind
of a big blonde you know classic
American looking dude I guess and that
they had followed him around the bars
and had heard him talking about being a
med student I find that hard to believe
but that could be the case um so they
saw him standing on the street like near
his buddies and apparently one of the
cult people like lured him close to one
of their vehicles now again there's kind
of different things a couple different
sources I read said that they may be
because sometimes the cult members they
had police uniforms so some and badges
and stuff so sometimes they would wear
those and pretend to be cops right so
and they had friends that were cops so
sometimes a real cop would like be along
with them when they were doing illegal
[__] so because they had friends that
were cops so I don't know if that was
the case here but some sources said that
it was that they had police uniforms on
like jackets that said you know polio on
the back or whatever and they had uh and
everything so he might have thought so
Mark kill might have thought that they
were
cops so they got him to come up to the
vehicle other sources said that maybe
they just asked him if he wanted a ride
or something like that and he came over
to talk to them and at that point um
little sarapen and one other guy whose
name was um they just called him like
Pon Tores he they grabbed him apparently
and kind of got him inside the
truck now there was a point where they
kind of slowed down the truck and Mark
apparently jumped out and like
ran but one of the cult members yeah
freeze at him and he did I guess because
he thought the dudes were cops or he was
just used to doing what cops said or it
was just I mean he was pretty drunk um
so maybe he just did it
automatically but regardless he did stop
running and there there were actually
two vehicles one behind the other one
like you know one was backup in case
something went wrong so the other
vehicle they basically like muscled him
inside the car uh at gunpoint and then
handcuffed him like kind of knocked him
upside the head so he was kind of
unconscious so put him in the back of
the second car so they drove kind of all
around the back streets and stuff and
then they took him out to the ranch now
they left him in the car
overnight now right before Sunrise the
caretaker guy kind of felt bad for him
and went out there to give him something
to eat like he gave him some eggs and
some water and
stuff now they kind of kept him around
the ranch for about 12 hours
but then constanzo and his other cult
members came to see him and were like
yeah this is a good one this is like a
good one you got so they wrapped his
eyes up with duct
tape and then they walked him they had
his hands like handcuffed behind his
back and they walked him to the shack or
the cabin or whatever and then they kept
him in there all night um
constanzo raping him uh multiple times
times damn and torturing him um you know
cutting off body parts and whatnot what
they cut off of him I'm not really sure
like what it was but that's that's what
they always
did um so they did that and then for
like 12 hours and then they led him out
to this field and then
adalo basically like I don't he didn't
decapitate him cuz I saw a picture of
the body when they dug it up his head
was still attached it looked like but um
they basically like chopped him on the
back of the neck and killed him with
like with a machete and then they
chopped the top of his head so they
could tap take his brain out and then
they put the brain in theang in the
anganga um and then they before they
buried him they cut his legs off like at
the
knees but later on like little sarapen
said well oh well that didn't have
anything to do with the ritual we just
did that so it'd be easier to bury him
but I don't know what they did with the
legs they probably put those in the pot
too I'd
imagine also and remember how I said
earlier like how a lot of the cult
members that had killed people they
would have NE they had necklaces that
were made out of um backbones yeah so
what they would do was they would take
like a a coat hanger that was all
stretched out they would after the
person was dead they would put the coat
hanger through the spinal column and
then they would leave an end of it
sticking out of the grave
so that they would wait a while after
the body was decomposed they would come
back and pull on it so they could get
the so they could get the [__] out
easier that's that was the story and
then you could make like a necklace out
of it and apparently Lil seraphine was
like so jealous that like some of the
other cult members had spine necklaces
and he didn't have one
[__] and he was just like I said he just
admitted that like he's like yeah man
they were so cool like I didn't have one
that was a real bummer and I'm just like
holy [__] this is so [__] up up but
yeah so and as a matter of fact when
they took Little seraphine out there to
show the cops where all the bodies were
they asked him where's Mark killroy and
he said right over there it's like
that's where the wire is sticking up and
there was like a because like I said on
the documentary I saw they had the thing
and it was like a little piece
of little piece of coat hanger like
sticking out of thing so you can pull
this spite out they thought of
everything I'm just like that is one of
the most [__] messed up things I've
ever heard it's awful it's awful um so
yeah
so they found his body uh they also
found a whole bunch of other
ones um 15 other ones to be precise uh
as far as I know they identified most of
the people that they found buried out at
the ranch but I believe three of them
are still unidentified these are just
people that they picked up and
killed uh so there was that now uh yeah
so what they did did was like the cops
after they found out that all these
bodies were buried out there they
basically made the cult members that
they had arrested that they had captured
they took them all out there at gunpoint
and like made them dig all the bodies
up um you know so there was that so they
found 15 bodies all of which were
mutilated all of them were men they had
all been killed over a 9mon period they
were able to identify mark killroy
because of his dental records they did
find a Jawbone and um like I said most
of the other people were identified but
three of them were not as far as I know
those people have still not been
identified um among the bodies I believe
uh was the victim that was killed after
killroy now I thought this was kind of
interesting too in light of uh Sarah
aldr you know the kind of second in
command now she had been dating a dude
before she got together with constanzo
who by the way picked her up by
what the story I heard was that he
essentially ran her car off the road or
like was trying to make her pull over
and she wouldn't and then finally he
like blocked her way so she had to pull
over and then he very aggressively was
like you have to go out with me because
I I just wanted to talk to you and yada
yada and like event like you know most
people most well 99% of women in the
world would be like please [__] off I'm
calling the police because you're
obviously deranged but she kind of at
first was reluctant but like oh okay I
guess you're all right yeah well how'd
that go so um so yeah but she had been
dating a couple dudes just casually like
before she hooked up with Alfonso right
because she was just like a normal you
know pretty girl so she had like a
couple different dudes going one of
those dudes was named Gilberto
Sosa now right around 1989 it seems
after Mark killroy was
killed adalo found out that Sarah was
talking to Gilberto again right and he
didn't like that [__] not one bit even
though like I said he seemed more into
as far as being in love
with um his male lovers of which he had
two one of which she called a ma like
you're my man and the other one was
you're my woman I can't remember which
one was which but he had a whole thing
like he had a like a trio thing going
like a thruple with the two guys but
Sarah was in the mix too and I'm not
really she seemed okay with it I'm not
really sure how that was going
but so he found out though that she had
been talking to this ex-boyfriend of
hers and he got mad about it he's like
okay well he's going to be the next one
we're going to kill him next now
evidently like after Mark Hill evidently
Sarah not too upset about this was just
kind of like uh okay I guess that's how
that [__] goes all right so she didn't I
don't think she participated but I think
she was there like I think she watched
it
happen um and they did kind of a similar
thing they basically like tied him up uh
They al adalo cut off his toes first and
he didn't put him in the pot though he
kept him in his pocket like his
souvenirs and then he raped the guy um
you know tortured him tried to you know
cut off various parts took some skin off
[__] like that and then he killed him
and then this dude again which one the
dude that he's killing right now the
dude that was Sarah's ex-boyfriend from
like along before she was in the cult
okay he's a Mexican or no yeah everybody
was a Mexican except for Mark killroy as
far as I'm
aware [__] dastardly man that's
the word that's the word damn oh and
then after they killed
Gilberto um they all went out for
burgers and fries which was apparently
something that they did every single
time they sacrificed somebody that was
like their little ritual hey we're going
to go out for burgers and fries and they
chill out we're going to Five Guys or
what and [__] yeah yeah but that was
their favorite thing that was like their
ritual after they would would go get
burgers and fries one of the things that
cracked me up was that one of the
places I don't this was on one of the
documentaries I watch it's just a detail
that struck me as funny was that adalo
constanzo he would always meet people at
this place called
VIPs which was I guess he thought it was
fancy because it was American own or it
was like an American Style Diner but the
documentary person was like it's
basically like a Denny's but he thought
it was like super CL
so he would always like meet people
there which I thought that one might
have been a move up for what he which I
always thought was very funny well it
depends on where where this is happening
that might have been the best thing in
town maybe so yeah Zanna said wasn't
killroy the son of a state senator too I
don't know if he was so I think like the
main um connection that he had was that
his uncle was in like big a big up in
the Customs uh thing I think that's what
it was so that's why they well and plus
he was an American and he disappeared in
Mexico and you know so that's everybody
like wanted and he's like you know kind
of a golden boy type thing so that's
always going to that's always going to
like play well in the media which you
know terrible to say which like I said
that's kind of why whenever like a
pretty blonde white woman gets kidnapped
or murdered or something like that
you're going to hear way more about that
than if the victim was a prostitute or a
drug user or black or something I mean
it's better than it was but that still
happens that still happens
happens so so yes they go for Burgers
and Fries um I think there was one more
murder after that one who was like a guy
that they thought had like betrayed them
he might have been a cop like a corrupt
cop I can't remember but there was like
another guy that they killed after that
after they killed Sarah's
ex-boyfriend so when the Mexican police
raided the ranch they other than all the
bodies which that's bad enough but they
also found 243 lb of marijuana 10 108 G
of cocaine uh 12 Firearms including
three submachine guns and uh 11 Vehicles
which had phones in them which was a big
deal for 1989 obviously they also found
the anganga the iron pot uh inside of
that they found a brain a human brain
which obviously was Mark kroy's brain
they also found a goat head a bunch of
chicken feet uh there was a roasted
turtle in there some herbs a horseshoe
and some coins and a bunch of animal
blood
I love that one of the things that I
read said they found no signs of
cannibalism like that makes [__] better
they did all this kind of stuff it's
like well at least they didn't eat
anybody I'm like okay all
right now according to the guy uh in the
documentary the one of the Brownsville
investigators that was uh interviewed in
the the thing that Zan does that me they
said he well he said they found 23
bodies
in the mam moros area but I wasn't clear
if this included the 15 bodies found at
the ranch because the santaa ranch at
least from my understanding is about 20
miles outside of boros so I don't know
if he was talking about those 15 bodies
and then like an
additional uh eight or if he's saying
they found 23 additional bodies in
mamores that they couldn't it that they
think was related to the cult but like
not exactly they also found a further 40
bodies around Mexico City that kind of
had the Hallmarks of the cult sacrifices
as I said I don't think these were ever
definitively linked to this particular
cult but it looked like the same deal
you know what I'm saying so that's why
they're saying you know there's 15 16
that are confirmed but then there's all
these other ones that they're pretty
sure with the same people but they can't
really prove it you know what I'm saying
now on the same day that they were
exhuming all the bodies at Santa Elena
the ranch adalo took the [__]
off and he they later found out that he
had gone to a holiday in in Texas in
Brownsville and then to macallen Texas
and then he came back to Mexico City he
had an apartment there now it wasn't
just him he actually escaped with Sarah
Sarah ALR and um three more of his cult
members that'd be uh Martin Rodriguez
Omar Ora AOA and Alvaro Deon Valdez
who's otherwise known as ldie they all
had nicknames by the way one of them was
the cat one of them was the butterfly
you know they all had names this one was
called ldie I don't know what the [__]
that means but that's what he was called
so I'm saying that the fact that as soon
as they dug the bodies up at the ranch
and he knew he was [__] he got the
[__] out of there so I was like like
well obviously you don't believe that
you're magically protected from the cops
cuz otherwise you just sit there and be
like hey they can't get me I magied the
[__] so obviously he didn't really
believe that because as soon as he heard
about it he's like let's go we're out of
here so he [__] took
off so they started like basically the
US and Mexican authorities like kind of
you know got together and did like this
whole big man hunt looking for the
castano and all the rest of the [__]
people so they did a bunch of raids they
did they arrested a bunch of the cult
members all this other kind of stuff but
for a while um they couldn't find uh
those five they couldn't find castano
and the four that had escaped to them
one thing they did the Mexico City
police um I think later there was some
kind of um uh I don't know if I'd go so
far as to say bad blood but I think
there were some kind of like little
conflicts between like the Mexican and
US authorities because I think the
Mexican authorities thought that the US
authorities had made it look like in the
media that they had solved the [__] when
really it was kind of more the Mexican
authorities that did that because in the
interim because for a long time the cult
had had connections in the Mexican
police like because a lot of them were
corrupt but by the time of the you know
by the time of the mark killroy Murder
by the time they were you caught um
another guy had come in and he was
getting rid of like all the corrupt cop
he was really cracking down on it so
that was another thing too so it might
have been just like a matter of time but
this but the dude that came in his name
was something I can't remember what it
was but he was really cracking down on
uh corruption in the police force and he
knew that they were in with the cartels
and so he was really head up to like
catch these people so there was that too
so they started investigating they're
like okay well there were all these
other cult style weird murders that took
place in Mexico City like between 1987
and 1989 and like I said they're pretty
sure that that was the same people so
they're like well because these are
occult practices they started going
through Mexico City talking to
informants and they were talking to like
people that knew about about Witchcraft
and [__] like that they wanted to get
into the Witchcraft community and see
what everybody knew so by kind of
talking to people there they heard that
adala was probably hiding out in a place
called uh qu how does how do you
pronounce it I looked it up quok quok
quok I think is how you pronounce it I
try to write it down because I listened
to somebody talk to say it you know what
I mean so I wouldn't get it wrong which
was kind of like the outside of the city
right and um they're like yeah so
there's this apartment building and we
heard rumors that he that he was there
so the cops sent all of these officers
out to kind of look around now they go
in a grocery store and they found this
dude that was in the grocery store and
said hey I saw this really tall woman
because remember Sarah alte was like you
know pretty tall for a woman she was
like 6'1 6'2 something like that so he
like saw a woman that matched her
description and then while they were at
when the cops were at the supermarket
like talking to this guy that had seen
this really tall woman they found this
person
who was buying a whole bunch of
groceries with like a with an American
like a us$100 bill so they thought that
was really suspicious so they followed
this guy and it turned out that this guy
was staying in an apartment um right
near there and they said this guy is one
of the dudes um Deon I think the one of
the guys that escaped with constanza and
he was constanza and he was like buying
groceries for him that's what they
thought um also around this time I'm not
really sure if the Mexican authori did
this or if this was somebody else that
did this but one of the things they
wanted to do to freak constanzo out was
that when they had raided the um the
ranch you know uh Santa Elena and they
found his inanga and they
knew how superstitious like the cult
members wor they're like we are going to
burn his cauldron and we're going to put
it on TV so they hope that he saw it
really like to kind of freak him out
like psychological warfare so I don't
know if the cops did that or if somebody
else did that but they did that like
because I saw the footage of it and
apparently he did see it and it did like
freak him out so it worked so so they
figured out that they were all hiding
out at this
apartment so in early May of 1989 the
cops surrounded the building and then
you know traffic's going by us they kind
of waited till the street was empty and
then they try to were going to raid the
place but then this suspicious black
vehicle pulls up in front of the complex
and the cops are like who the [__] is
this and they walked over to see who it
was and AD Doo meanwhile was in the
apartment was looking out the window and
he saw the cops so he opened fire at
them um thankfully only one of the cops
got just winged in the arm like he was
fine and I think like just one bystander
got hit but again they survived so
nobody got killed in the well you know
no none none of the good guys I guess
got killed but yeah so he just like open
fire and then as a distraction he
started like throwing money and [__]
like that out of the windows like cuz
people were coming by like oo money you
know what I mean um so there was that
now adalo eventually just kept shooting
and then he ran out of ammunition and
then he was just getting pissed off
because I guess he knew he was caught so
this whole shootout went on for about 45
minutes and he was I guess didn't want
to be taken
alive so he says to
Deon I want you to kill me and Rodriguez
who was kind of his main dude like his
main boyfriend right
and Delon was like man I don't want to
do that you're the Godfather you know
what I mean I can't kill you but he's
like no you have to do it um he's like
if you don't I'm going to like [__]
you're going to be my slave in Hell or
something like that like I said they
they believed all this
stuff so apparently so Delon they put
him and um Rodriguez in the in like a
closet little room or something and he
just shot him so both of them died so
yeah he told him to kill him
and he just opened fire open with a
machine gun so the cops come in and they
get in the apartment and at this point
Sarah Runs Out screaming her head off
acting like she's been kidnapped and oh
my God I'm free and all this other kind
of stuff which like I said I kind of
think all that was [__] but we'll
get into that in a minute um
so so they come in they find they
arrested everybody that was
left now for a while they weren't sure
if adalo had maybe faked his death
somehow so they had to do like
fingerprints everything like that but
that actually was him like two of the
guys he did actually die everybody else
basically said that they were all
innocent like we didn't do and Sarah in
particular was like no I was forced into
this [__] I didn't even like know what
they were doing I was just starting with
my initiation um they were holding me
prisoner and making me do this and blah
blah so everybody that was left in the
apartment other than the two dead guys
they all got brought into custody
including some other cultists that they
tracked down later um that were in the
city but they found them later on uh
they were living in another apartment
building that con uh the constanzo owned
now so yeah so they all got arrested and
brought up on various charges um they
ended up charging 14 people and most of
them they got like murder was like
obviously a big one but some of them
were just like on drug running charges
um you obstructing justice things like
that so the kind of three big ones like
Sarah aldr Elio Hernandez who was kind
of the head of the cult and Lil
seraphine they got convicted of several
murders each um and got sentences of 67
years each I believe um Delon the one
that had
shot uh constanzo and the and Rodriguez
he got 30 years now all of of these
people um if they are ever released in
Mexico if they ever come to the United
States then they will also be charged in
the United States so I don't think
they're going anywhere um because the
thing about it was that in
1998 their sentence is not Sarah's
sentence but the other two guys um some
of the other cult members their
sentences were reduced but they were
just reduced like to 50 years so they're
probably still going to die in prison
and like I said if they ever get out and
come to the US then there's warrants out
for them too so they will get charged
here also so now as I mentioned Sarah
came out uh and talked to the press in
2003 and said that she had nothing to do
with any of the killings um that she was
like well constanzo is dead and it's
like you can't possibly know what
happened um you know and she thought and
some people maybe still think this and
there might be some truth to this I'm
not entirely sure but some people
believed that because of
constanzo's
connection with you know kind of higher
up uh politicians and cops and stuff
like that um that
maybe maybe they rubbed him out because
her story is that he didn't have his
Lackey kill him her story was that the
cops came in and killed him freshen that
up yeah okay and she argued that because
he knew so much about so many powerful
people that they maybe had him killed
that's her story but like I said I don't
really know if that's true she even
wrote an autobiography again in the
early 2000s and she kind of
told her side of the story in which of
course she made herself seem like
um blameless she basically said that she
was taken hostage by him that she was
afraid of him um you know and that he
made her do stuff but that she didn't
even really know that much about the
killings and that she wasn't there when
it happened happened and all this other
kind of stuff and then she also said
that after she got arrested that she was
mistreated by the police that she was
raped and tortured and all this other
which you know that might not be untrue
I'm not entirely sure but I'm saying
that like a lot of stuff that she's
saying was probably [__] because
according to everybody else like even
all the other cult members and stuff
that they got to talk about it that
Sarah Al was absolutely a willing
participant I don't think any of them
said that she actually did any of the
killings herself but all the [__] he's
she saying about her being forced into
it or you know that she didn't know
anything about it was [__] because
they said for some of the stuff she
didn't actually like swing the machete
or anything but they said some of them
she was absolutely there and that she
seemed like just as into it as all of
them were so I don't know you know how
that would go but yeah so she is um
again still in prison they all still are
as far as I know only two of the cult
members that they're aware of are still
at large um oido Hernandez um and Pon
Taurus uh they're still wanted for Mark
kroy's murder among many other charges
and as far as I know those are the only
two that are still at large they think
they caught everyone else even though
some of the other cult members said oh
there's lots of us out there which may
entirely be true I'm not really sure
because like I said this
isn't um even though this is obviously
very extreme but there are a lot of
people who
practice
this religion you know but you know
obviously all of them aren't going to do
[__] like this because this was Way
Beyond The Pale Way Beyond The Pale so
you know damn I mean wearing SP still
out there yeah they got to be in as far
as I know got to be in mexic I mean they
might be dead by now well like I said
how old would they be by now you think I
think they were all fairly Young when
this was going on but this was like the
late 80s and they're probably all in
their
20s so so they'd be in their 60s yeah
they'd be older than but they could
still be alive but like I said
considering the line of work that they
were in yeah um I'd be surprised if they
were still alive but it's
possible it's Mexico it's probably a lot
easier to vanish in Mexico than it is
United States not quite as electronic
well they are now but these
[__] might be just in the
underground you know they might even
have bank
accounts you know oh hi so I grab the
kid's tail and she goes what you do
don't go anywhere you're going to come
on the show she's like come on the show
poy look at Pooky we've only had bam on
the show a couple of times yeah she was
laying out here she she was there for a
while like sleep but she was like when
you guys start talking to the lights I'm
just out here yeah I'm gonna go sit and
look out so what the comments say
anything um I'm just I'm looking at your
oh no I was talking to side quest hero
that that's my [__] veteran buddy
she's a an Intel veteran and uh in
working in [__] Supply and report and
everything and we're just talking about
Army [__] business she's my sister I
I understand we agree on a lot of [__]
[__] relationships don't [__]
belong in the military situation we're
talking about like the best roles for
females in a
military situation Intel and Supply yeah
but
like you go through history you're going
to find that the special forces of
female is sex
operative those girls are real heroes
they having sex with dudes that they
don't even [__] like to get
information to [__] save lives on
their side poor girls I mean better them
than me I can I I wouldn't be able to do
that yeah those are the Commandos you
have to be a good [__] actor yeah you
got to be an actress I'm not really good
at that actress and a porn star and
everything to [__] convince these
[__] that you like them yeah I'm not
I'm not to get information that's all
the James Bond shit's all [__] no
James Bob would be a female
[__] well because people don't
suspect him as much evly in the books
haven't read all the books but evidently
[__] in the books James Bond was
partially a sex operative I'm going to
have to look that up because that'd be
really interesting well yeah see if that
it would make sense yeah I mean it would
make sense that's a that's just like in
the movie The Jackal just like in the
movie The Jackal with [__] uh with uh
Bruce Willis he made a move on the gay
guy to get his ID well yeah like I said
it would be useful right any any kind of
attack was [__] job you're tring to
get somewhere is getting information and
you got to do that whatever way you got
to do that without getting your ass
killed and if you got to go out it from
a sexual angle then that's what you got
to do because a lot of people aren't
expecting yeah Jackal Willis went it at
a sexual angle I think he killed that
guy though too you know he he was a
[__] psycho but he got his
ID yeah yeah I just saw what you said
you can handle when your bro dies when
your lover dies it's much worse yeah
yeah I don't think there should it's you
got to keep the Infantry
[__] Single Sex
organization and you know part of the
reason
why they didn't approve of homosexuality
and homosexuals being in in in in the
Infantry back when I was today or even
in the Army because they were
afraid of
relationships you know I mean everybody
has to be equally expandable because
some of the orders you have to issue
will result in the deaths of other
people well what if your [__]
boyfriend is in that group you guys see
you know what I mean you say well I'm
not going to send that one I'm GNA send
the other group no everybody has to be
equally it's more of a thing of like
favoritism I guess more than or along
those lines you can't be any favoritism
has to be Stone Cold indifference that's
what actually works in the
military there isn't NE the human
emotions that civilians have there's too
many lives at
stake you
know somebody has to die yeah you know
it that's in the [__] infantry and
also
armor armor was like that too and
[__] a and combat Aviation
similar yeah and I I feel like I don't
know if this is the case across the
board but I do kind of feel like men
have a harder time dealing with the
death of a loved
one maybe than women do do you think
that's the case
maybe maybe just because men are not
encouraged to like showcase their
emotions or deal with their emotions
there's some um evolutionary psychology
whenever you talk about that you can
have all these people [__] jumping up
and trying well no I'm just wondering
like what you thought about I think
[__] based on what I've
seen women have a tendency to attach
themselves slowly to men but they can
detach
quickly in other words it's hard to get
a girlfriend but she'll break up with
you very quickly so you're like well how
did how did that
happen well when you look at females not
only human females but animal
females usually what ends up happening
in a [__] um something like a lion
pride or a wolf pack or mostly like a
lion pride or even in a even in a
primate
group the females are the main
characters in the group the males kind
of come and go some new males can chase
the old males away and take so you can't
get too attached cuz that that one might
not be around exactly so you have a
situation with humans is is you're in a
farming Community you have a man maybe
even a child by him some other men come
kick those dudes asses they kill your
husband grab you they even kill the
child cuz that's really what lions do do
they [__] and even primates do that
they kill all the children to bring
they're starting over and the one women
have a tendency towards uh Stockholm
syndrome where or just like survival
where it's like survival I better like
they're going to kill along with this
[__] the old guy that was here was
too weak to defend me he failed these
other guys these new guys they're kind
of hot they came in [__] kicked ass
these other dudes you know he's a winner
the other dudes were losers this is the
new guy you know what he's all right
he's he's being nice to me and he's
protecting me and this one will protect
so that [__] will never happen again
that's that's I think was the female
mindset even
outside of of humans you know what I
mean other species of the females are
like that too there's people think that
there's a division between animals and
humans there isn't humans are animals
there's just other species all those
other species they act real similar to
us I mean we have some different [__]
going on because of our brains but it's
not really as different not that that
different so we are more complex women
tend to like
guys who are sexy when they think sexy
they think he's competent he's he's
strong he makes you may feel safe he can
provide he's bringing meat he's being
bringing money they tend to like that
that way other dudes don't come and take
your [__] and disturb your life but when
that does happen that's a stronger man
so he that might be a better deal and if
you're back in these days [__] in in
didn't really it's not like you had a
lot of options you didn't have a lot of
options but back in the caveman days
this was happening when you were still
in your teens and your man was maybe in
his 20s or his 30s they didn't live that
long so what that meant was is that
everybody was kind of hot back then
they weren't old [__] dudes [__]
from a PO industrial civilization with
[__] huge guts and [__] you know
these were
all uh people in their [__] animal
form you know kind of uh they were
physically fit all of them were it
couldn't be physically unfit although
they did have old people and they took
care of old people it was already bad
they weren't that big of [__] they
were just kind of like ah die old people
like in
msar there off a cliff they've been
found they found uh neander tals who are
not human but related to us that were
old they didn't have any teeth or
anything and they lived a long time
people were taken care of cuz you took
care of your parents right I mean and
your and old people had something well
that's kind of why I mean some animals
do that too will take care of a um you
know a member of the group that is not
able to like elephants will do that and
stuff like that so it's not just a human
thing but that's kind of yeah how they
know like this is when humans like got
their Humanity when they started taking
care of people when when they started
doing things that they knew wouldn't
reward them necessarily we're taking
care of a person cuz that's a person
well they're saying they didn't reward
them but it probably did because you
have to look at the situation they were
illiterate they didn't have books but
you had old people and old people had
memories they could tell you things they
could tell you stories you know what I
mean well and they knew [__] they knew
[__] from the past so they were kind of
old people were your uh your resource to
tell you what what you should do and so
they were probably doing but they still
had I mean I imagine they had a
connection with yeah they still had a
connection with them because that's like
your parent or your you know your
husband or whatever it's like they felt
grandfather emotions like we feel like
you love that person so it's just kind
of like so that's another reason to like
take care of them like keep them alive
as long as possible Erica Lyn said I
agree Jenny I think women expect the
husband to die first women usually live
longer but maybe men lose themselves
when they lose the mate first yeah I had
noticed that like I said I don't think
it's true across the board because
everybody's different but I had noticed
that women I mean
obviously they grieve and they feel
horrible like when their mate dies or
something like that but I think they
spring back from it quicker but that's
just a generalization side quest is uh
she's female veteran is [__] say some
[__] what'd she say I couldn't read it
all she's given her humans are just more
self-aware yeah yeah um there's a
scientist who said the first sign of
civilization is a healed bone yeah yeah
because somebody had somebody take care
of that person right yeah yeah that's
actually a good marker yeah cuz like I
said that's not I mean yes it benefits
the community as a whole because it's
like if that person is a hunter that's
you know for example and they broke
their leg and now they can't hunt well
it's like obviously if we take care of
that person they'll get better quicker
and then they can get back out and help
us yeah you know what I mean all those
protohumans uh I'm not sure
Australopithecus but they were probably
okay but Homo erectus [__] homo
hobis neander all those they were humans
they just weren't as advanced as us um
because all you got to do is look at
animals cats and [__] they do a lot of
things that are humanlike well our cats
definitely do they're just not quite as
good at it they their memories aren't
quite is good and so but they're just I
I consider they're very childlike yeah I
just consider them kind of like human
children because they come across like
our cats come across just kind of like a
toddler or maybe like a little bit older
than a toddler little bit older they
have empathy they they know but they
can't really stick to anything because
their their memories and their con but
you know I'm sure even Homo erectus they
probably had human behaviors and human
responses to things they could stick to
it a little bit more yeah they're like
no no no his arm is hurt let him let his
arm heal up he'll be okay you know so
they were probably at that level yeah
cuz like I said even nowadays like
domesticated animals dogs cats stuff
like that can obviously feel empathy for
humans they have some kind of human
emotions our cats um they can deceive
yeah um they know what you're feeling
like they know if somebody's upset or
something like that they seem to like
respond to that I've seen a video of a
girl pretending that she was crying her
dog was concerned yeah beside Bes yeah
so you know so yeah they have empathy
they know when something's wrong and
they try to help you yeah yeah so so I
don't think it's that crazy that like
you know we're not yeah you know our
brains are more complicated or whatever
but I don't think that's like as huge of
a difference but that said getting back
a little bit to because this is
interesting because next week's show is
going to be on Valentine's Day and
traditionally we had always done like a
killer couples sh on Valentine I know
it's [__] up but you know you know how
I do um but I have the poll that'll be
up on Friday and I have a couple killer
couple kind of shows in there but I also
have some
other Valentine romance adjacent kind of
stuff like Curt Courtney you know Kurt
Cain and Courtney Love I think I have
that in there like stuff like that stuff
that I thought was like appropriate for
like a Valentine's Day show but coming
at it from a [__] up perspective like
I
do however
I kind of feel like a little bit this
situation um ad Doo constanzo this is a
little bit of a killer couple situation
I'm not saying that he wouldn't have
done the [__] without her because he
absolutely would have but I'm always
kind of curious about that Dynamic and
I'm curious how involved she was in all
of this [__] like did she watch the [__]
happen was she into it um
and it fascinates Me That by all
accounts you know Sarah
aldr was a
normal person seemingly this is why I
don't trust normal people but yeah she I
mean she was a college student she was
straight A she you know she was
cheerleader all this other kind of stuff
like everything you think of as just
kind of like All-American kind of thing
I mean she was Mexican but she went to
school and college in in the United
States but it kind of fascinates me that
somebody like that
could have this dark side of
them that was prob probably like the
darkest side that you could ever
actually have hey on this side of the
Border I'm a straight A student and a
cheerleader and like everybody loves me
but then on this other side of the
Border I'm involved with a drug cartel
who is by the way also tearing out
people's spines and wearing them as
necklaces I mean that seems a little
crazy and I'm like I said I'm kind of
fascinated more I'm fascinated by male
serial killers also like by their
pathology and stuff but I'm kind of
really interested in couple serial
killers which this kind of qualifies you
know what I mean kind of yeah even
though like I said I he would have done
the [__] without her but I think it's
kind of like interesting the dynamic I'm
I'm interested in how women get sucked
into this because it's not common there
are female seral Killers obviously you
know you got Alien War got Bell gun it's
like people like that there are women
that are [__] up but it's not common
and I'm always kind of interested in how
that Dynamic occurs and I think that
particularly in this case because she
seemed so
normal to most people and they didn't
know anything about this other life she
was living the weirdest thing about the
the couple serial killers is that the
victims who have survived said that the
woman was worse than the man that's
which is always that's fascinating to
mea and I said I wonder if that's
because I wonder if that's and maybe I'm
talking out out my ass I'm not a
psychiatrist or anything like that but I
always kind of wonder if that's maybe a
product of women being
more likely to be people Pleasers trying
to make him happy right so I kind of
feel like they get involved with this
dude and they love him and it's this
whole a little bit of a Stockholm
syndrome kind of situation maybe and the
more she's the longer she's with him the
more normalized the [__] becomes and
there comes a point where she's just
trying to make him happy so she's trying
to do more [__] up [__] than he's
doing to impress him to impress him and
then and also I think that might be
what's going on and then maybe to secure
her safety that too like look I'm
crazier than you are don't kill me right
it might be that too it might be that
yeah because I'm sure because there has
to be at some level that woman has to
know this dude could snap at any moment
and do the same [__] to me I mean they
have to know that even if not
consciously so maybe that's why they're
doing that CU it's like look I'm your
I'm your partner in crime I'm crazier
than you are I am also doing all of this
stuff and worse and it's kind of like a
kind of like a
uh a kind of an overwhelming feeling
what what's what's the word like like an
overload of emotions right negative and
positive emotions fear d
hatred love everything all happening at
once they must be like extremely over
stimulated oh I'm sure must have kind of
a
euphoric quality to it maybe for a while
I would think that would wear off
everything kind of
does that's the thing it's like I kind
of I mean my like I said I'm not a
psychiatrist my only experience is
actually being a woman and knowing what
our mindsets are um I don't understand
like I've never understood like women
that write to serial killers and like
are like fan Girling over serial killers
cuz that's [__] up I'm fascinated by
them but I'm not attracted to them I
think they're vile but I think the
reason I'm fascinated by them is because
they're vile and because their thought
processes are so different than mine
that's what I find fascinating I don't
find them
alluring in that way yeah but some women
do so I can kind of see where that
switch might happen even though I don't
have that
personally but I intellectually I can
kind of
see how it could
happen like remember when we did the
show and this was a while back like on
one of our killer couple we did a killer
couple show for Valentine's Day and it
was British couple so we talked about um
Brady and hendley who I've always been
fascinated with I've read like a ton of
books about them because that's always
interested me he was obviously a psycho
and he would have done [__] without her
with or without her but the thing about
Myra hindley was that she seemed again
perfectly normal and had she not met him
that [__] wouldn't have happened I don't
think no I don't think she would have
have she she would have just had a
normal unremarkable life Myra was just
kind of a [__] solid five or a six I
would call her a six she was very very
average but kind of attractive on the
average level and for some reason that
dude really tickled her fancy and he had
a lot of control over had that been
another guy who was decent she wouldn't
have
[__] she wouldn't have gone on that
path no not at all I think she would
just had a regular she just got married
and had kids and just been a regular
[__] emotional dependency and her
need for love and from this dude and
this dud end in the worst somehow
[__] impressed her he's torturing
little girls and she's getting into it
and she's like watching it a man I can't
imagine
yeah unless maybe if I had seen a video
of it maybe when you're there it doesn't
quite seem the way it sounds but I can't
imagine that either um like I said
there's something to be said for and
this is kind of how a lot of Cults work
too like coming back to the whole cult
thing um because we've done a lot of
shows about that and the you know the
story goes most people that research
cults like pretty much anybody can get
sucked into one and I believe that um
especially if they come at you from a
way that doesn't seem particularly culty
and that's how a lot of them come at you
because they know if they start out with
the heavy [__] that everybody's going to
be like yeah no thanks you know what I
mean they're going to walk off so they
kind of come in at you kind of subtle
you know what I mean and I get that so I
kind of feel like most people given the
right circumstances and given they were
approached in the right way could
absolutely be convinced into a cult and
then by the time you get in
there once you've passed a certain
line it's hard to get out
psychologically even though it's easy
for us on the outside to be like oh holy
[__] when this x like horrible thing
happened why didn't you just [__] run
but by that point they're already kind
of brainwashed yeah cuz they've built up
to that like to us we're just hearing
about it from the outside and we didn't
experience
this whole buildup yeah you know what I
mean so it's like by the time they got
like hey we were like cutting off
people's ears everyone was just kind of
like okay with it because they had built
up to that you know what I mean and they
believed in this case it's this is kind
of not a traditional cult because they
already believed all of this occult
stuff so it
wasn't in a way it was a little bit of a
buildup because they're just kind of
like well we were doing all these animal
sacrifices and Robin Graves and [__]
like that but hey wouldn't it be like a
lot more powerful if we actually like
killed a person
and every by that time everybody had
been in it was hey that sounds like a
good idea you know what I mean and they
all kind of get and he kind of slowly
acclimated them to that right
so I kind and that's kind of the scary
thing this is kind of what fascinates me
about cults and about this kind of stuff
and about again like the dynamic between
serial killer couples is that
given enough of a buildup you can
probably convince most people to do
pretty much anything I don't know maybe
depends on their level of
Development I've seen all this [__]
before I know how it goes you know or
I've at least seen it on paper I just
wonder I'm fascinating because it's like
I wonder if because I always kind of
Wonder like nowadays no nobody's G to
suck me at anything because I'm just
kind of like nope no I don't want to do
it I don't want to do it I don't want to
do anything I don't want to do anything
that I have to get involved with other
people so just don't talk to me
but I kind of wonder when I was
younger would I have been sucked into
had they come at me at the right way or
had or had like some dude come at me in
the right way and just like built up
into it where it just kind of like got
to a point where I was so brainwashed I
couldn't get out and I kind of wonder if
that you know cuz I was kind of like a
people pleaser you know a lot of women
are so I kind of wondered if that would
have happened to me had I been
approached at the right time so I think
that's what kind of fascinates me about
it and that's what kind of fascinates me
about these kind of like couple
situations where women get involved in
this
[__]
and do horrible like I said I don't
think in this case I don't think none of
the um cult members that confessed
anything I don't think any of them said
that she did anything like she didn't
cut anyone's head off or anything like
that with a machete but she was there
for some of the stuff and was apparently
fine with it so she watched some some of
it I don't think she did any of it but
there have been cases where the women
did the [__] and like you said sometimes
the women were worse than the men yeah
so I don't know that's just a dynamic
that kind of fascinates me okay well uh
I guess we got it finished up is there
uh anything we want need to talk about
there I just wanted to mention again
because I forgot to mention at the
beginning of the show that we have a new
Patron named Kelly G so I wanted to say
thank you very much Kelly G if you're
listening um not sure if you're
listening right now if you're going to
be listening later I'm sure she probably
will be but thank you very much for
becoming a patron and all of y'all can
become a patron if you want I mean most
of yall are probably already or you know
give us Super Chat so that's fine um
like I said you know basically you get
to vote on whatever the topics
are and you get to find out what the
topics are before anybody else and blah
blah blah so there's all that it's kind
of like fun uh perks so Danny says uh as
Tom says shut the [__] down Jenny yeah
it is getting kind of late but this was
was a fun show even though it was a
[__] up topic uh so thank you very
much for recommending it uh because yeah
this was pretty messed up wasn't it yeah
it was pretty messed up yeah Tom said it
was messed up what's up what's up oh
okay shutting it down Okay so we're
going to shut it down for this evening
thank you very much for dropping by and
hanging out with us thank you very much
for your super chats uh remember to like
share all of that kind of stuff and we
will be back on Friday night for our
Sidetrack show which is always fun we're
going to get drunk and talk about
[__] uh which is always enjoyable so
hopefully you can join join us for that
and we will see you guys again on Friday
night good night